[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo
around what's going on let me know how
the levels are sounding
what is popping
sunday the lord's day
you already know what's going on gerald
mack keeping it very respectful making
sure everybody's respectful when they
come through in the congregation
necromancers there what's going on here
comes another great show
tell y'all man lydia master what's up
deaf mobile what's up
lloyd metroid what's up
i see gaming fire
hogwarts legacy yeah oh you stole my boy
i'm gonna say that on the show
i'm gonna have fun with that yeah it's
coming to the gangs coming to the gang
sith lord what's up man you rocking that
packs in blue yo bro oh that's what's up
yo do me a favor lord put those if
you're on twitter put those up on
twitter so people can see look at the
new packaging if y'all coming through
the packs y'all got the shirts make sure
y'all say what's up you know we gonna be
outside all the lords are coming all
four are we gonna be
here in like six seven months we might
do a giveaway with the with the
merchandise yeah we're gonna do the
giveaway you buy a merchandise you get
you get what's the
raffle ticket
get the raffle
oh except king did the one-on-one with
boom oh i missed it i didn't even know
he did that okay cool shout out to
christopher hart what's going on for afc
what's up dip down games in anime yeah
oh god oh i'm pushing p today oh yeah
yeah we pushing p okay so what we doing
today now you know we always got the
sour on deck that's the sour water man
we focused up stay focused man get that
get that sour advanced gg.com do what
you got to do cold iron lord you know
what it is right so then
after that we got the new new we got
that slamming great you got to get that
slamming grapes and i'm telling you
guys hit me
slamming great bro i'm telling you it's
i'm gonna literally the code in right
now you're gonna say go get y'all that
slavic grape that's my new joint right
now so there you go push a p right there
on the checkout use code iron lord get
that little percentage discount do what
you do but i'll be focused up man i got
rid of the coffee and i'll be real with
y'all like no crash that um
stuff and i've been loving it it worked
it worked it's official you know i'm
saying so it is what it is hustling
motivate what's going on
[Music]
what's up
seth ross what's up
you know what i mean guys hey man make
football jerseys black and gold we had
hockey jerseys but yo they mad expensive
to make so we did it like limited
edition right
yeah i like actually some joggers you
want to get the jogger we got that we
don't have them
we got the new one
i thought that was a women's job
we got joggers though jog is real what
the hell did you guys put joggers on
they came up i'm gonna say like
probably like
maybe like six months ago out of nowhere
teespring was like yo jogging you know
who put them up from c unit from um log
map
see you there who did the wwe review
when he was scribed he cop
the jogger for his joint so it is good
i'm gonna send you a link yeah we got we
got the jockeys y'all
i don't know
[Music]
man my girlfriend my life
daddy
anyway so look we gonna be back
and we would get y'all back in the realm
down for some rp merch hit the link in
the description man hit the link in the
description
[Music]
because we'll read it live on the
podcast yes if you if you don't put
nothing if you don't put your name
you're going to be an ominous yeah don't
be anonymous man no no momma said buddy
whoa buddy with the booty pop
anyway look we will be back it's just
the lord's old school man we can't keep
it old school for a little bit we're
thinking about doing um
an attic is really like this probably
going back to maybe
two a month where it's just the laws we
gotta take it back to that's plus kyle's
doing a lot you know what i'm saying
yeah they're still going doing a lot so
we you know
[Music]
it doesn't matter
okay all right i don't know what that's
about but it is what it is
yeah okay
yo we'll be back
we'll talk to you in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this
love my city but i'm still by coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
who
let's do that again it's not even
cheating mosey going down over to the
website go check it out whether you're
gonna get that focus for them gaming
session that energy a little perk for
the gym we want to get some swag some
merch maybe an ice shaker go right on
over there check out the products but
again really cool products they don't
hide behind any type of proprietary
blend
nonsense it's all transparent as far as
the ingredients the label green tea
caffeine kind of a healthy form of
natural caffeine none of that crash none
of that stuff so yeah again go check it
out you run in there you add it to your
cart use that referral link that we got
in the description and then you make
sure on the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by advanced
gg so check that thing out
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
mistake me for addict if i can imagine
it's cool to give you some advice and
invite your girl to your squadron cause
if you don't give her that option you're
gonna be single player like siren you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david royalty and not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in a crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursued but
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
yeah that was crazy wow anyway hear you
hear you and we are
live
welcome
to the iron lords podcast damn they lose
elderly lords podcasts what's going on
eldon rings has literally took over the
interview yeah they lose there's no
internet no more it's the elded internet
listen clearly
welcome to the alden lords podcast llc
and also the lords of gaming.net episode
number 249. and it's time to introduce
everyone as eldon lord in their oh lord
i still we gotta talk about that it is
another glorious sunday we're back at
the round table on the lord's date and
today we've got hogwarts legacy
the initiative in trouble hmm
starfield updates and gran turismo
sevens outage to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
okay here we go
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original
knights of the realm here at the round
table my co-host with the colemo my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man eldon lord addict of the attic show
how we doing sir
doing pretty good man it's been it's
been a good morning i've been up since
like nine o'clock
snitching on me when you see me up
at four o'clock in the morning
i said look at here
xbox snitches
finally uh
what yeah that's why i'm permanently
offline
[Laughter]
you
it's been a good morning man we gotta we
got an interesting show for you guys
today we got an interesting show no
guests yes uh so it's just going to be
us for uh
you know king could probably count as
two personalities yeah that's just true
we won't have to put them on time on the
intros you know saying go back to the
essence but what you've been playing sir
i heard you finish off i've beat
triangle strategy uh there will be a
review out for my triangle strategy uh
our review the iron laws podcast right
will be up to uh monday at 1 30 and i am
going to premiere i don't normally do
that but people suggest oh no you need
their thumbnails like anticipation for
it yeah uh it's 26 minutes long
okay
and i and i'm sitting there like man
that's long and then i looked at like my
four's a review a person that don't play
racing game was 24 minutes long
it's okay maybe my reviews are just that
long
the dying light to review is like 22
minutes long
you already know and of course we have
our most technical gaming lord the solo
game who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patriot of
the iron bank my man eldon lord
sovereign how are we doing sir
i'm doing good not eldoning anything but
that's fine
got
zero gaming going on this week um
the only thing i got to try out i played
the against switch because that's all i
had on me um i played the kirby demo
so i played the kirby demo okay it's
nice i mean there's parts of it they're
very linear and then they're parts of it
that kind of open up more so i don't
know how much of a true opening it must
be good because bg is playing it so
really oh he hasn't really messed with
nintendo games but he he said from that
demo he played they got something yeah
it seems very cool i mean it still seems
super easy like they give you two
different uh difficulties at least in
the demo and one is like super super
easy and then one is supposed to be
super hard
according to them but it's still pretty
easy so we'll see the simplicity of it
is what kind of gets me a little bit but
the platforming seems good like the game
looks great runs beautifully so we'll
see
um and then also on switch i played some
of the mario kart the new mario kart uh
levels oh how're they going how much
that was going on they're they're cool
um they seem kind of simplistic like it
doesn't seem like it seems like they
like they res them up right and and they
made them fit within what mario kart 8
is why is it the same
line of thread i hear when y'all talk
about nintendo it's simplistic
[Laughter]
it's 4k it's funny
it's 120. yeah they got
don't see 4k nintendo in the same line
ever
absolutely
it's like there you go what am i going
to say like it's like it's rudimentary
else can i say i'm not gonna lie
like it's charming it's charming it's
charming i don't know no man they didn't
even know
they priced them listen
but the prices the price if you bought
into that whatever the the online thing
this is
honestly this is great because you're
getting
hey there you go so you have it you're
gonna get all these new tracks through
next year or something like that it's a
lot of tracks
so
they're not giving you america nine yet
but they're giving you this so they
definitely rock it
yeah it's nice to see like they have a
lot of the uh the tracks that are from
the mobile game in there so to apply you
know actual mario kart mechanics to
those is cool but again they seem you
know kind of rested up nice placed in
there
whatever but again it's it's quote
unquote free so
that is all i have done this week before
not free continuing
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who simple like
skyward sword lord metroid
[Laughter]
[Music]
we don't see it we don't see you
who defends nothing less than that for
human experience it is the leader of the
fraud alert movement oh beloved lord
king are we doing that better than blake
cobb oh what happened what happened yo
yo blair stop running your mouth
errol spence and terrace crawford is
laughing at you they're all gonna laugh
at you
this old
this old contender this old prospect
this 30-year-old price old prospect
could be a 30-year-old prospect
[Laughter]
that's how you know how garbage this old
is so
he headlines a card over there in the
zone and his joint he stole a
catchphrase from ric flair
whoa he stole that from ricky so he's
running around doing this
yo shout out to alexis rocha he beat the
brakes on him yo i i texted dave
yesterday
uh raquino yeah
yesterday and i said please on god on
everything let this dude beat him down
and it happened i wish i did combat talk
yesterday
because i had so much jokes it was the
best thing in the world yesterday shout
out to blair blair i hope you're doing
bad shut up
but um you know cause he's talking mad
at me he told he said
and this is what i don't like
this journeyman prospect
i'm gonna say
earl spence is cursed
he talked bad about his family he talked
bad about his car crash
he said he said all types of stuff and
i'm like bro
a man almost lost his life i don't play
with life yeah that was crazy so god
humbled you last night please take the
message
anyway what you've been playing with so
real real quick though before you move
on to the games how did my my young gun
dues is how did how did he do oh i
didn't watch that i just tuned i just
told you you just tuned in
speaking before smoking and before you
move on to the games i got i got one car
back did you see a non-professional
combat boxing with the strong men did
you see the straw man the dude that
played the mountain thor
versus the world's strongest bed they
got it in and the other dude got his
head pitched this is the eddie what's
that eddie dude he's a big dude yo yo he
looked good though he had his little jab
going he could tell he was trying to
mountain
yeah the mountain did that thing yeah
they don't know i'm talking about real
like real boxes and stuff like that okay
you don't want this man this man like
six eight yeah it's crazy 350.
and 350 with not a hint of fat yes get
away from me
i just want to talk about that
[Laughter]
anyway
yo shout out to phil dominus maximus
aurelius spencer
for um
dropping so many gems this week
um i i really didn't expect him
to to do what he did with game packs and
i said man
it was a stealth drop dudes didn't know
that it was coming out they thought that
it was um
not gonna show up inside game pass
but tunic showed up in game pass yeah i
get a try yeah how is it and shredders
showed up oh shredders yeah yeah stratus
look fire i ain't gonna try to transport
that one either but i gotta i gotta try
it this week so so tunic if y'all guys
don't know
um and you know
he did it all natty oh he did it all
night
natural
so
tunic is if you if you don't know it's
like zelda and and and star fox had a
baby okay
it's the cutest little thing
and it's nice and it's all zelda
it's the wonderment of the world it's
it's a it's a real beautiful game and
you know some people was trying to say
it's like the souls game of zelda no
it's just if it's just a real zelda game
you know and it's it's really dope you
get your sword you get your shield it's
a real zelda game and there's a lot of
stuff it's not in english it's in some
weird language
and
you have to figure things out so i love
these games now that's making you figure
things out shredders is so dope it took
me back to um 1080
1080. yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't like ssx tricky mm-hmm
how that beats because the trailer the
beast was one that i was getting
yeah okay
it's it's something if you miss
snowboarding yeah you know uh get it in
because it's it's it's dope
elder ring
all right so i do apologize guys um i'm
gonna stream today after the show i'm
gonna stream elder ring after the show
okay i'm i don't know when car gonna
stream that's what i got
you gotta stop stitching you gotta stop
thinking you did me dirty on social
media yeah
god supposed to do this cocktail because
he lost
when the king lost the king was
streaming so
high gloss but i told attic right yeah
all right you know what i realized
though
what's up i i need to stop being too
willing to be streaming these things
i've been streaming like the day they
came out and then i'm not thinking about
myself
that's right
so i gotta i gotta ask this though
because addict and i will talk about
this a little bit yes
what is it about eldon ring or these
type of games you're like i'm not doing
anything i it don't interest me like
that
it's it's masochistic
it is like it's literally i'm gonna tell
you what it is i'm gonna tell you what
it is
like it's one of them joints
where people are not really watching the
two name for the game
yeah they like yo that joint messed me
up i can't wait to get you that's what
it is if you remember that time that you
called me on the phone and you were like
yo you playing tomb raider yes he was
like yo did you make it past this part
yo he was so upset that i made it past
the part oh the overlapping the opening
[Laughter]
it's not the difficulty per se because
we've been playing difficult games all
our lives
you guys just went
and played
a world's first race
lowered levels and i'm like that's
difficult for sure i'm like so it's not
the difficulty i know why why he's
comforting adam's like he's comfortable
there i get that yeah i i just i want to
see it cuz i know i know how you are but
i know how you are you're going to get
good at it i know you're going to get
good at it and that's what this game is
unnecessary so okay this is your segment
i'll go i'll go all right so here's this
thing called margaret
right okay so i didn't know nothing
about him right so i'm running around
the world with the cane and the hammer
yeah yeah yeah i'm 61. hawk saw me fight
that dude yeah
but see this is the thing that's the
story right
so the king is doing everything but the
story
and i said how do i do the story oh i
followed the trail all the way up so i
followed the trail i go into this castle
and i'm still i'm i'm i'm level 61 i'm
wrecking shop i got i got actions i can
kill stuff i don't care i fought uh um
marguerite the the foul
broke him down i just smacked him in the
face chill on the side let's let the
rock get him
take over and
and i felt so superior yeah so i'm going
around the castle i'm like nothing can
stop me in here nothing can stop me yo
addict tell me if this happened to you
i walk to a room i open the door you
talk about the night the door
the door shuts behind you
and
it goes black the screen goes black what
and you hear it do goal
and then when the lights come on he is
beating the
what's funny is when i was streaming
that when that happened like you can
even go back and watch him like they're
going to be someone in here with me
and it's pitch dark
dark the only thing it kind of reminds
me of remember the the destiny
uh strikes oh
what you call it blade yeah yeah yeah
yeah the dark blade
oh that's fire that's fire he got me i
had to go back and get my stuff
but
and then he don't do it again because i
told wifey i was like yo check this out
and then um i said he gonna slam the
door behind me
what he did you just go in the room and
you fight him oh but um that's that's
all i'm playing but i just want to give
a quick um synastics because dudes just
asked me about the batman if y'all see
them johnson boys johnson boys was out
here that was dumb i see the picture
that's fine i like that
my oldest boy and my youngest son um
you know took him to get haircuts but we
went to go see the batman and imax right
so
um
for for individuals that are upset
about this movie
um you're seeing batman year two
you're seeing catwoman year one mm-hmm
um
you're seeing
whoever the villain is
year one
all right is two things that happen in
that movie for where the second movie
can go
but
this movie is
if y'all ever picked up detectives
comics
it's not a batman book it's a detective
comics featuring the batman batman
[Music]
this is that okay
all right so if you if you want to see a
batman movie
this is probably the greatest batman
movie
because
it it's not about bruce wayne he don't
even like bruce wayne he's bruce wayne
right yeah he's kind of buried bruce
wayne completely he killed bruce wayne
off
and he has to revisit some of the things
that about bruce wayne and go through
those traumas and he sees that
said don't spoil anything i know i see
no i'm not responding i'm not spoiling
anything he sees those traumas revisited
so he has to um
you know go through those traumas but i
i give this a saying
it's not a superhero film
okay
so you individuals out that's not batman
and i can't stand by this and it's the
film that i've ever seen it's an uproar
yeah um
because they used to pump this they're
used to a summer blockbuster batman
movie this is not good it's not that's
that is intimate moment
of the creation of a character
so if you guys saw daniel craig when he
first was james bond
that was that was before he became sean
connery okay that's that was before he
became refined daniel craig to me is
always the beginning he's the rough
stone that got chiseled into sean
connery's sophisticated bond
and this is what you're seeing here but
what you're learning in this movie is
batman is a detective
and this is the first movie that touched
on batman actually being a detective
you know so you can't hate on it you got
to love it we're going to have a round
table review as soon as cogs see it so
we can do spoilers and all that stuff
and talk about it in depth but
dudes beyond my timeline and all my head
talk about it's the worst movie ever and
i'm like no you just don't know comic
books don't
okay okay okay
it is what it is you gotta have an
appreciation for it yeah you gotta have
an appreciation for that to understand
because you're gonna go in and you're
like man there's not enough action and
to me they did a good job of balancing
it all where the action was still there
so it's a real question so how did the
little one like it because that to me
that's kind of the gauge because i don't
know if i should take my nephew to say
he wants to see it but i don't know if
it's going to be appealing to him
he's nine he's nine okay
mine is 11. all right so
he loved it
okay but he
i don't know if he loved it
because daddy loved it and he told the
brother loved it i did right and he's
and he's happy to be out with the guys
right and he he was cohering through the
whole movie but remember he loves the
arkham games
right okay when he saw and remember in
the arkham games you do a lot of
detective work yeah you do yes and he
said he said daddy this is just like the
game
and remember when you go to this place
because he's in his place is in that
movie that's inside the game
so and he's like you remember when you
go to this part and you got to do this
yeah i remember that so
maybe yeah he really did like it because
he can correlate it with the game
because it does a lot of game elements
um so yeah
it's very intimate very nice it's a very
nice intimate film
no doubt no doubt and of course we have
given into himself the shinobi lord
cognito spreading that realism around
the ilp not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
definitely shout out the last they
immediately just uh shout out to
colleagues put up something on the um
anniversary tip man really cool to see
what's going on had the defining duke
joint episode going on talking about
that uh little fallout of what's going
on in with perfect dog which we will get
into as well and uh some funny
conversations about food where batty is
absolutely hilarious man
onion sandwich no because they didn't
make the bet they lost bananas
it's over
was part of it too he's trying to really
yeah make sure this gets 1 000 likes and
the dukes are gonna have to eat it and
you know we ain't nothing
what was crazy was he trying to rope me
into it and i said no no exactly
shout out to jess gordon with all that
craziness when he came on that's what's
starting that's i guess it's a uk thing
or whatever anyway
[Music]
about that
see you next week they out here making
spaces on you videos on me it's lit
i love it i love it
so we got that
if i do ultimate we had chris reagan
pull up talk about all what's going on
with halo on shout out to the last word
ibontist ty got travis yo we had an og
on granddad gamers cats from manchester
uk
he was from the day king you would have
loved it from like
the spray painting the graffiti on the
train
you know what i'm saying like the core
tenants are hip-hop stuff you know what
i'm saying and he's a destiny content
creator which is crazy so yeah like he
was dope we had him he tagged on trains
bro he
that he from the era you know what i'm
saying like yo i was like yo we talking
about you know with ducey and that would
do tagging
yeah you know what i said
yeah because he he broke it down he's
like
that's when you knew he was hip-hop
because he's like the core tenants he
was like you know the mcn the djing the
break-in and the graffiti you know he's
like yeah i couldn't rap i couldn't dj
he's like i love the coach but he's like
i had to do the tags and that was his
thing so yeah it was cool it was cool
what was his name when he tagged oh he
told us too he did tell us you got to
watch the show he did mention it i
forgot it off rip but um yeah he dope
dope show had that going on for me as
far as um gotta shout you out cake
before i play it
that nine monkey's a shy led side yeah i
do the devil the demos up right now on
xbox um for the free go check it out two
player
yo it's the essence of the joint sorry
like they got that cookies hold up
nine monkeys
apparently i guess he's been out on
steam already simple art style
two-player co-op but he's got the staff
the cool thing is the fighting joint
because you got the punch to kick on all
that but then you got the parry you got
the dodge you know what i'm saying and
like
the charger and then the start yo they
got good voice acting
yeah they yo they burnt your village
yesterday they put your village down
they left you for dead the shaolin monks
come to get you you
[Music]
and the story is low-key good like it's
a very i was like you're kidding so i
shouted you out on defining duke too
because i was like yo this is a little
joint on the low and i think someone
tweeted me today was like yo it's coming
you know to xbox officially or whatever
so um yeah i know it's already on xbox i
brought it well the final version is out
oh yeah i purchased it wait wait wait
wait wait up to your face
because
[Music]
during those times i'm not even bringing
up switch games anymore because oh this
is a switch
though
i got it off
[Laughter]
[Music]
yo shout out to dvo resolution games
they came through to check in
yeah bro it's so i would take it down i
want to take my green screen but i'll
show y'all but it's so cool even the
cops are jealous
bad people hit me up how you get there
shout out to the resolution gate bro it
was fire can't wait pc edition coming
outside but still rocking with that and
um yeah it's been pretty much it so i'm
gonna get a super chat before we get
into the top oh asus said what game we
talk about we talk about um9 what is it
now monkeys of shaolin
little simple beat em up but the good
art style good story great voice acting
ragdoll physics
it's cool man i i do like it you know so
check that out but yeah what we got for
the super chat song give me a second let
me just copy paste these last ones it
just came in okay i got it
oh we got
render with the two dollars we chat when
are we getting the elden lord's
podcaster
there we got god's hitman 1
for the lord
he laid you down for the lord
wow i love that name
i hope xbox let's cod devs slash team
make and work on halo let 343 make
something else wow okay that came out
that came out of left field but hey
whatever okay
there we go
tyson joe three dollar super chat
where's the sour it's the lord's day
i got you bro i got y'all so look today
we still we got the sour we got the sour
still make sure you get that that sour
watermelon is lit we got new sours
coming let me tell you about that but
what you got to mix it with right now
that's what you got you got to mix it
with that slamming grapes that slam it
focus up man get focused man i'm telling
you use that code get that 10 iron law
you know what to do with vstg continue
cog the chemist i gotta push up yeah i'm
pushing p right now i'm trying to make
that pushing this powder right now y'all
got to get that
it gave me solid batman animated series
vibes yes that that very dark sort of
like uh moody vibe
then we got freddy fox five dollar super
chat
king you hit the nail on the head piece
i know i know that hate it i hated it
it went in
okay i know i hated it when it went in
looking for the wrong thing i thought
the movie was fire i love the detective
side yeah if you go in looking for the a
batman movie that you've seen before
you're gonna yeah you're gonna
just go in with an open mind
that's it
don't get ninja member for 20 months
thank you sir morning lords happy sunday
good to be part of this realm and shout
out to all the lords holding it down for
the vow of the disciple race
you still have to do this
when y'all get it down pat listen i'm in
the elder ring right now
me and addict gonna get it in the days
oh hit up yeah dj
in the chat too man he'd be raining all
the time helping everybody i'm blessed
man i'm an elder oh okay
oh okay i'm gonna go once and i think
i'm good
it's a new day
wow
we're gonna we're gonna hear you saying
the same thing
[Music]
looking at the two bottles here that
powder when that
don't gameplay about it i gotta i'm
gonna do it i'll probably do the twitch
though attic i was gonna talk to you
about that do the trick link that to
your joint okay let me tell you how very
easy yeah yeah tell me what you did make
your twitch joint links
and then you just hit the button and you
go live now stop playing around oh
that's how you do it i didn't do it
i don't care
no more i don't know
you ain't got to mix it up
i don't have to disconnect my mixer yo
it's just like when you're drinking your
focus you just put the water in you just
stir it up
and you're focused right yeah focus on
man i'm gonna be cooking up over here
anyway
i can't stop doing over eight ounces you
know what i'm saying eight ounces on the
cut that's it two scoops max 16 ounces
right now hold on let me talk
you probably gotta do y'all cooking it
up but y'all use it too much no more
than eight ounces bro all right
[Laughter]
moving on last week's phone results are
in and the people have spoken when you
hear reports of development departures
at a game studio where do you think
there is cause for concern the winner of
the three-way i o people at 42 of the
vote was the messy lords i don't care
y'all just mad when your favorite dev
leave for a bigger bag with the ops
group coming in at second place at 33 of
the vote was not concerned the industry
is very fluid and there are many reasons
a dev could leave that doesn't doom the
quality of the game group and in last
place with 23 of the vote is very
concerning especially when multiple
developers leave the project early and
when the cave has not been released so
the messy laws win they say people just
mad
attic what you
think yeah it is what it is man all
right no he's not the messy lords i'm
the messy lord yeah you're the mess he
goes in the way but i had to ask addict
what do you feel
[Laughter]
they stupid in the chat why are they
just mad why why are you just bad so
they left for a bigger bag why would you
be mad at that because they'd be scared
they scared right now of corey balog
leaving
because they had to fake corey ball long
accountability
a lot of information that says he is
leaving but he's not the director like
the the guy directing it now is not he's
it's not him so you know i don't know
let's get over to microsoft cut it out
so we can get god of war
i'm done
remix baby
we catch this in the chat from the old
man twitter
you got that what's up
hold on let me grab that
let me scroll back up from new york neo
mental power book six cognito 2017
before youtube
what is this
what is this lord cognito doing on this
channel
you know how like when you watch
something it's just like adult for
adults only
but they're going to put like substance
abuse at the beginning
disclaimers
if you need rehab
yo
what's going
[Laughter]
we got the state of play addict this is
your topic man hogwarts what's going on
so we we uh there's been a lot of
speculation on what exactly what we're
gonna get from hogwarts legacy
and first off i want to you know kind of
briefly
go over it's interesting that it was
that it had its own state of play
instead of you know wb coming up
formally announcing it so we can talk
about that a little bit
and then i want to give you a general
ideals on what your opinion was on what
was shown i don't did everyone here
watch that gameplay
oh yeah oh yeah no
no oh my gosh because kate didn't watch
it
the last day to play i saw it no
once i heard wb let sony do the state of
play i was like oh wb bro
i just want you guys to general opinion
and we could start with soft since king
didn't watch it i'ma watch it right now
i haven't watched it right it's like 18
minutes like 18 minutes
i'm gonna watch the gist
[Laughter]
so cliff notes
so for me let me give you a little back
story it's funny like so i i love harry
potter i've not read the books but the
movies i've always enjoyed like wow this
is cool and then once you started
getting into the dark stuff i was like
wow this is really cool so i i'm an
unapologetic harry potter fan so last
week um
the second thing that came to my mind
after oh i'm about to die
and i had the kidney stone the second
thing that came to mind was like damn
i'm gonna miss harry potter this weekend
because i had purchased tickets uh for
my sister's birthday to go see the harry
potter play on broadway
so that was my gift to her for her
birthday okay so it was for saturday and
i'm like so when it's funny it's
wednesday i'm dying and then the second
thing that pops into my mind damn i'm a
miss harry potter
so i felt i said i felt considerably
better and i went to the harry potter
play with it it was amazing the harry
potter cursed child on broadway is
freaking amazing
um so i'm a big harry potter fan
i did not know what to expect going into
watching
this is
the harry potter game that i think all
potter fans are like oh my god this is
it it's like one of them joints like
foreign
that's what i said i don't even rock
with looking yeah let's see your kick
reaction y'all that's what i was like yo
they did that if you're a fan of that
they did that because they did that
yes i mean i i just i didn't know what
to expect it was just going to be a
linear story based game it was going to
be an rpg and how deep they were going
to go into like the lore and to make it
really feel like it was your story in
hogwarts and that's exactly what they
did they gave us the harry potter rpg
that people have been wanting forever
with you as kind of the central
character and you being able to sort of
pave your way through hogwarts at the
same time there is an underlying story
because somebody something sinister is
always going on at hogwarts
i saw it
bro
yeah from the look of the game from the
way that you doing combat and magic
from the way you could sort of
the kind of secrets that are within the
world because again if you don't read
the books and you don't know the back
lore you just watch the movies you can
tell there's a lot of stuff in hogwarts
that's super secretive that you just
can't
so they have to expand upon that and
again
any old game new movies with the um
the fantastic beasts which is telling
dumbledore's backstory right yeah it's
real so
yo i all i could say it was one of those
things i was watching i'm like yo yo
it was um i was super super super
impressed with what i saw
um again it's it's supposed to be coming
out this year so i don't have any reason
to believe that what we're seeing isn't
what we're gonna get
and man i am super excited i sent it to
my sister because she doesn't play games
at all but i sent her i said watch this
and she was like oh i'm like oh
justin has a ps4
i guess maybe i could try it there like
it was
i'm very excited very very excited
that's what's up king where we at now
that you saw a little little piece of
that well i i saw a lot of it um
yeah
i like the over the shoulder i i
understand why sony showed it mm-hmm
the most eyes would be upon it to be
honest with you um
because you know stated plays actually
chart really well so
um what i did see they had the
atmosphere down packed when he was
walking through the hallways and talking
to people um they had a little dialogue
tree and stuff like that and then i saw
the combat and uh um i saw the open
world aspect of it because it turns into
like uh top
type of looking thing
um
it looks
really
polished
and
i think
like you said it's gonna launch this
year i don't think this is one of those
games that's gonna get delayed i think
it's going to actually hit his mark i
think it's going to come out because it
looks polished it looks clean it looks
it looks ready to go so if anybody
actually likes fantastic beasts or like
actually likes harry potter um i think
they're going to have a it's going to
sell well yeah not for real like i'm
saying i'm on the same type of time
y'all like i am not a harry potter guy
like i tried a couple times i won't buy
it though unless it's in gameplay oh god
here we go
the caveat the caveat you know why
mm-hmm
it's
a movie book based game
um
and
those licensed games tend to not work
well with me okay unless it's about
characters and stuff did you do
guardians did you do guardians yet
you got it
now okay
but see this
thing that's happening right now and you
think it's like really a joke i want to
pull myself away from this game but i
won't revenge no i feel your favorite
yeah
just so you know this this is a hundred
years before the books yeah so this is
kind of its own lore yeah it's a
licensed game but it's not a movie like
right also then it's going to tell me a
different story yeah
it's like an 800
yeah yeah so like i i'm not so like i
said but i know some of the law i know
what's going on but i admit when i saw
this i was like i know why sony showed
this they yeah these this studio they're
they're confident that you know what i'm
saying like it looks really good it
looks so fire very it's extremely
ambitious like they're doing a lot
they're doing mixing they're doing
overwhelming you go to schools college
feels like it feels like the hogwarts
bullying yeah it's like bully it's
hogwarts bullet then you dueling the
other students and all right let's go uh
and like then i was like all right so
then at first i was like oh it's just
going to be
hogwarts college the game right at first
then when they did the second part and
you going out in the world and doing i
and i saw the spell joint i don't know
how i feel about the frames so so i saw
yeah
30-ish on some parts i'm nitpicking i'm
nitpicking the game look beautiful i'm
nitpicking but um i mean the the sheer
diversity of the spells
it really
really looks good i think you're like a
fifth year student you pick your house
oh you know what dave always finds why
they got a school named slytherin yeah
slytherin and they they don't be
sometimes they be the other ones and you
know i feel like i want to be slippery
because let them sound like this so
funny like is this
it's hilarious it's not like it sounds
like it's the grimy yeah
gryffindor sounds like heroic yeah yeah
yeah
that sounds like the cornballs
yeah i ain't down with the hustle
they got the schooling you got the
classes whatever whatever the little
adventures outside they got dungeons
which i thought was very very
interesting and let's put our hands
together for the damn character creator
let's put our dance together they got
some full diversity going on in there i
like what i see for the options now i
know there is some controversy
apparently with this game based on
yes yeah though i don't i don't know the
lore but something you know what the
issue is people have people have issues
oh well
um
so
jk rowling has at some points made made
statements that
like transphobic
right that's some of deemed transphobic
um you know and you know as a result
there are many people who have tried to
sort of cancel her because of gotcha
gotcha and then i heard that her
involvement was not much in this game or
not right so
yeah so the thing is that the devs had
to come out and be like yeah you know
her involvement in this is minimal
because again they're trying to they're
just trying to make a game about
something that they love right and when
you start conflating
the like the the game world and and and
the world of the books and whatnot and
something that you love with whatever
the author said whatever when you start
doing that then all of a sudden now
people are looking at your project like
i'm not supporting it regardless right
and it's like as a game dev you're like
damn like i work so damn hard on this
game that i know people who love this
are going to go gaga over
and over this
it's possible that my game could just be
dead in the water so it's just one of
those things where it's like they've had
to dis distance themselves from her
right um but you know
come on let's be real like jk rowling is
going to make a bag and a half off of
this so um
it's just the reality of it all i would
say is that um i guess i'll give a
ratchet off is that i'll be addict is
that i did hear which was surprising
after all this because i didn't know who
was i don't know their history like that
i don't really follow harry potter like
that but i was surprised to find out
that the character you can actually make
a trans character so i was like oh okay
so they clearly are self-aware of
whatever the issue is that this person
said i mean in in the play in the play
so the the um the role of hermione
granger in the play
was originated as a black actress and
they sort of maintained that i haven't
really seen any versions of it that
maybe i'm wrong but the broadway version
like the original version that came out
on the west end and um in britain
was a black actress and the version that
i saw also hermione granger was a black
actor so okay i it's one of those things
like i guess they they've made a
concerted effort to be like okay we
don't feel this way right right that's
they feel like they separating itself
right from exactly yeah that's the vibe
i got the stewards of the property robe
and suck the monsters in
i can't it's like it's like it's like
the salesman you know and residual four
like what are you selling yeah
howdy he's about to say something just
roll up and suck the monsters in wow how
do you use my things
when it comes to like
the rolling activity like look i get it
you know it it it sucks to
to
[Music]
support something that you're passionate
about which the money might be going to
someone that's not you know definitely
uh not the best type of person in the
world but
it's like
i've always had that concept it's like
if you if i we if we have that energy of
one thing we have to have it with
everything you know we
there's corporations doing slimy stuff
24 7 we're going to just not go to
walmart not go to any type of fast food
joint and i go to target like you can
literally trace that i mean sony just
had some crazy stuff happen a couple
months ago we're going to just boycott
sony too
yeah listen it's a personal decision i
don't i don't knock anybody look that's
how i feel like
whatever the game is or or or dev or
someone that makes a comment for one
person there's two schools of thoughts
it's either one you're not gonna let one
person's comments affect the rest of the
team and still support what you like
right and then there's the second
thought that's like yo i'm not with that
i'm not with a person you know
denouncing a group or anything so i'm
not going to support it and to me
neither is wrong the only thing i would
say is that at some point it's where i
agree with addict is that you know at
some point
to be completely morally clean is very
difficult in this business
because at some point a game you love or
something you love is gonna have someone
or some entity associated with it and
you're gonna have to make a personal
decision so i don't knock anybody either
way it's just it's personal all i want
to say is the real important thing of
this shout out to the nintendo switch
coming in hot having this game shout out
to the nintendo switch
we don't know what the frame is gonna be
this thing this thing gonna look like a
bank
shout out to the nintendo switch coming
in hot and the devs have confirmed king
that they are getting the full version
[Applause]
it's going to be on 10 listen you got to
go with the sisters i think of your
you have to bend the knee to the switch
i got you out
such a huge like
downgraded version of this on the switch
that's not the point it's it's it and
we're gonna have to redefine the
definition coming into this because it's
gonna come in like a meteor
like
when when king you're gonna fight an
enemy a boss on eldon ring and he's got
a special move where he jumps up in the
air and he comes down like a planet
that's gonna be this game going into the
switch listen
the devs were forced to bend the knee
they know the dominant platform and they
had to make a decision it's best for the
studio
it's just business it's just business
y'all said you got to go you got to go
with the kids
they know the kids don't buy that
imagine the switch is the lead
yeah who holding who back now
nintendo really never markets third
party games
oh here comes soon as
[Music]
hogwarts legacy will be coming to the
nintendo switch
king they like [ __ ] polygons
they might get the game but let's be
real here they're not getting games
like it's gonna be a graphic novel on
the switch
equivalent to playing this game like you
know right now obviously switch is an
option you can get an option but you
know what else is xbox one's an option
is anyone here gonna buy this on the
xbox one
lead platform get it on the platform
that's going to run this game
not the 280p console attic when you when
you dominate mpds the way they do
this is what you got to do you got to
bend the needle who's winning the
generation i mean
mopping the floor with with the rest of
you guys
is to hit the switch the trap door that
throws that
lead platform y'all it is what it is
you got
don't even worry about it ain't no
scaling from that listen they're they
are going to get literally flat shaded
yo y'all remember number nine
[Laughter]
i just really looked at it right now
right so i did the extended look because
i did the highlight look first right
yeah somebody had it up for like five
six minutes i was like oh that looked
dope then i saw the extra stuff
there's no way
so i'm just i'm just curious
you know it's coming up for the switch
obviously there's nothing i mean they
got the witcher out on this one
this guy's clearly can work on this
richer
i want a
i just want an honest thing is that
there's game play out for everything
else is there gameplay
when it comes to this game like i've
always been like half and half out like
i don't really know too much of the lore
when it comes to harry potter but
i'm curious how they're going to do
certain things like i know they're going
to put the sorting hat on you so i'm
curious how that's going to function if
it's going to be like random or it's
going to go off maybe you can make stats
and something or you should kind of like
fall out three and follow three at the
beginning of it you're in the shelter
and they ask you these questions right
that base is your original stats or
what's funny is you could tell the
person that gives you the test yo i'm
not taking this test this is bull well
yeah i totally like you pick what you
want i would assume they give you the
option like do you want the sorting hat
to fix for you or do you want to do it
yourself like
i don't know because like
i think
it depends maybe when the game starts up
like
what's more important to you like do you
want to do because every
every
every cl uh every house to my knowledge
solved they represent something right
right
right but the thing you know what's
funny after after watching the play
right what
the play tells you is that
there's a lot of assumptions about what
goes along with the name of a house and
what that means right and it that isn't
necessarily the case it's always been a
stigma around what this house means what
that house means and it isn't true right
just that it so happens that certain
people have been in certain houses and
you know it's defined as heroic or evil
or whatever right but it's not that the
the player really makes it clear that
it's realistically yeah but let's be
real here it's the game they're gonna
make it what the general ideal of these
houses are like that's my opinion what
they're gonna do
man
unless it's random unless you put that
on and they don't give you a choice it's
a random thing that gives you one of
four houses i feel like that would that
would make people mad i don't know why
that would make people mad because i
know the harry potter
nut nuts i'm gonna call them nuts
because they're crazy
my friend amber literally had a wedding
that was harry potter themed but yeah
so it's just like if you don't give them
the option to pick the house they want
to know
i heard you again and i watched the
thing it said it said yeah you could
pick you out that's why i was laughing i
said slithering i said you can figure oh
i can pick that yeah you can see it say
i saw the they they showed that the
story had been put on his head i didn't
hear that yeah i heard that in the state
of play when you watch it i heard the
commentators say hey you can you know
students or whatever can pick which
house i remember hearing it but maybe
hopefully whatever well it's going to be
curious how they do it like i hope
they because clearly you you'll be able
to study certain arts you can like
master certains and not others
i'm hoping they let you like
you take a test or something because in
the actual lore to my knowledge like the
sorting hat picks for you okay you can't
do that in here so i'm hoping like
like they they start the character
developer maybe it's like a little bit
of an rpg yeah a skill tree into it
depending on what you put in that skill
tree yeah where you go in what house or
maybe maybe that's how i would maybe you
act they actually ask you what you're
doing the character creator and then
they do like a cinematic like like even
like it's predetermined already you know
what based on what you input i don't
know they're going to figure it out but
it does feel like they they're doing it
but no it looks good holiday 2022
and y'all gonna like the poll because um
oh
i mean if they this is
super ambitious y'all if they pulled
this off the world looks nice the world
looks beautiful
different flying mechanics
yeah this could be one of them joints
yeah this could be one of them joints if
they pull it off i saw the griffin he
flying first of all he's flying the
pegasus i see him flying on his on his
this switch ain't
doing this this is the lead player i'm
gonna tell you this though i'm gonna
tell you this though there's a lot of
kids who love that's what i think about
what the what they know which is like
this
[Laughter]
when they load up that switch it looks
like a lego game
when they see the final fantasy 7 flat
you dude
they're gonna say oh no mommy this isn't
what i saw
i think you on it they i think they
forced into action because they know
that demographic
all them kids love harry potter they
gonna make this work
it's gonna sound like gangbusters on a
switch
i feel like harry potter's big
turn like gangbusters i don't know if
like a lot of kids gravitate towards now
i see a lot of adults i see more though
i feel like that demographic is more you
know he's older now yeah but you kind of
probably like you got to keep the
generation you know what i'm saying
but see the thing is like in order to
make okay harry potter is mainstream but
it's mainstream to a certain demographic
audience it's like it's not like
everyone right like in order to get it
to that point you would have to restart
that
series
and restart putting them out on the
biggest
that that movie ain't coming out before
this game comes out
it's the same way with star wars
with um
uh star trek and everybody has a niche
everybody you know and harry potter
actually fits that niche those books so
it's like the vampire diaries those
those books sell those stuff is like
that so you have those people that's
fanatics about it i don't really think
that it's um
the younger demographic i think the
younger demographics gets pulled in
because it's kid-friendly yes
all right so
you have a hero uh well you have the
chosen one that's laid on in harry
potter and the stuff like that and they
can follow the story pretty good and
also you know keeps kids reading books
but at the same time this thing i sort
of open world to it
the cliff notes thing that i saw you
know they just showed you combat they
showed you the clothes you know and they
just showed you the over and the
fighting so when i went into a little
bit more of it y'all saying switch i'm
like
no
no
i said that about witcher y'all said
that about which how is that possible
it's getting you second
and it's moving out here it's coming in
hot room it's coming out you can fit i'm
sure you can fit a lot of games on the
switch but i mean for the people that
only have a switch that works perfect
for them but i would never play a game
on the switch that i have options too oh
they're getting sick on the switch
cyberpunk coming out for the switch you
know actually someone brought up a good
point in the chat oh they said uh
the sorting hat cause i remember in the
first movie it actually because harry
potter it wanted to put harry potter and
slytherin
and harry potter convinced him to go
with gryffindor so maybe that's how it
is like when you're on uh when you when
you put the sorting hat on maybe it's
like a mini game
in a certain way he'll he'll put you
where you want me or you could just have
him put you where they come out of the
dice rolling game
hogwarts
it's like then where do you want to go
and it just like says roll a dive roll
it down
anyway joey look fire can't wait good
topic so i'm gonna get the tax before
you move on
super chat
let me see let me see what we get he's
got a couple we got
[Music]
chat happy sunday lawyers in realm not a
fan of harry potter movies but love the
books but this game is a day one
purchase
to get starfield and harry potter back
to back oh my god elgin ring might have
game of the year competition oh you
gonna like the
imagine both these games came out like a
couple weeks from each other starfield
and harry potter and harry potter that'd
be interesting i don't know man like
unless like starfield shows up shows up
in big ways i think harry potter will
take that take that space i really do
because the thing is like
this is a good harry potter game and
we've seen through like spider-man like
huge demographic audiences that when
their game is done right they show up in
waves show up in droves yeah yeah so
we got akw five pounds super chat can we
sign this petition for cog to play elden
ring here's the link to the button
king already snitched the whole thing i
was trying to build it up so now yeah
blow up the spot it's coming it's coming
i gotta king's
very robust system that they use you
know what's funny somebody put a crazy
super chat
all this this hatred that can't be
getting they're going to give a switch
game he will be the final boss
ridiculous
then we got tyson lewis ten dollars chad
uh
what a dude family happy sunday to you
all and wishing you all a dope show
tunic is my jam right now yeah there's
so much tunic talk right now they're
talking about the secrets in this game
are crazy this is nice it's very good
yeah
and we got fez fest five dollars we chat
it's quote it's dangerous to rely on
teraflops as an absolute indicator for
performance
end quotes never forget that was from
mark cerny himself yes
yeah cause he got an unstable box that
flip-flopped
so of course you're not going to boast
about something that you don't you're
not the best then
i think we got we missed that we missed
a little bit uh i seen a couple that we
missed did we oh no you got up to it yet
no no you're good
just send me your ears i'm done with you
yeah
then we have the wise old game of five
dollar superset yeah i saw hogwarts for
real this week yet the most magical
thing i saw this week is how the
initiative made quadruple a disappear
at it again
let's see
very messy very messy we got donald taco
five dollars super chat if they can get
the witcher 3 running decently on switch
any game can run they just have to
actually put the time and effort into
doing it i mean yeah they hit that 30
frames it is very vaseline but it's 30
frames that is a cataract waiting to
happen
before we miss his member thing
yeah it was earlier before yeah i think
we did
he had like a member of comment i think
it was you know it's classic lame but
that's later before i think we miss
forte we definitely he just hit me he
said don't forget my membership chat i
need to i need to leave kingdom though
we are a drive-by surface
so clearly i'll find it keep going
that's right
yeah i i remember seeing it it just it
probably scrolled up fast keep going
i'll find it okay then we got flame
remember for 18 months okay cog is on to
something switch is definitely the
dominant platformer especially has game
of the year triangle strategy bend that
knee
talk that talk
let's go
look at that man you guys can check out
my triangle strategy review tomorrow at
1 30 p.m yeah oh yeah on the lead
platform right on the lead
it's the only place he can play he's
like
let's make sure he's playing is it
then we got the otaku fix two dollar
super chat just stopping by show us the
points
salute
then we have
a second the wise old gamer once again
five dollars this is crazy
i heard if you create a transgender
character in the game it becomes harder
than elder ring the final boss
apparently is jk rowling wow
we're not gonna comment on that we're
gonna leave that alone that's crazy
that's crazy
that is crazy
then we got don otaku five dollars super
chat ps fanboys that are still hurt
about horizon getting shot down by eldon
ring i'm trying to say hogwarts legacy
will overshadow starfield
yeah they try to
they mad though
akw with a five super chat can we sign
this petition for cog to play elderly i
read that the only thing yeah he read
that he read that no he said you missed
it so i was just one yeah
we read that stop trying to read it
twice though
oh you just asking them
just
this one specifically
you say wait he he said that we didn't
read it he said that we didn't really he
said you son you missed my super chat i
was bad that was it yo you was making
sure oh you was making sure he just
wanted it rather twice now that's all
that was like
i don't know because yeah very clearly
read that i know clearly i remember it
but but but there is a petition
to make uh to make cognitive plans
if someone would be so happened
to hand me this this link to this
petition it might show up in the chat
somehow
i can't wait till it's your turn again
anyway
yeah i i don't know where fortes is at
all right man i can't find it forte i
remember seeing it it's so crazy yeah
just write what it said it was kind of
it was the classic line that you always
said in the king and it was something
else for whatever reason is like gone
from
yeah it's like removed i don't know what
happened so forte if you want to just at
me or at us and then
yeah just rewrite what you wrote because
we want to we want to shout you out
brother for for real so we got
everything caught up until then all
right cool
so soft
lot going on with um perfect dog you
want me to set you up or you are good
go ahead set it up
so um
lit up my name we got a tablet look at
um
yeah initiative so report well shout out
to games industry dot biz report perfect
dog studio the initiative see waves of
staff departures an
analysis of linkedin suggests around 50
of the studio's core development team
has left in the last year so it said the
studio saw multiple exits across other
disciplines with writers directors
engineers and qa staff also leaving
later this year including game director
dan newberger design director drew
murray principal world building
jolan meyers amongst other senior
members and it said um uh the former
employees like departure are fast and
furious um several ex-staff described
the initiative hierarchy as top-down
environment with studio head daryl
gallagher and newberg controlling a lot
of creative decisions according to this
outlet at vgc staff were frustrated and
didn't feel hurt on key issues
surrounding development the team also
said it was surprised at microsoft's
leniency uh towards the studio's lack of
progress as a result and the final thing
that people are making the correlation
is some of the departures took place in
september last year around that time
that the initiative partnered with
crystal dynamics to create a reboot of
perfect dark this is a hot hot one saw
what we got going man
i mean
listen i i don't i'm not gonna sit here
and act like i have any idea what goes
on in the studio
and how this stuff works
what
what i will comment on is this
we still from the initiative's mouth
right we know that this the structure of
the studio is kind of different than
what we've seen in studios beforehand
right yeah the idea of and they
themselves we kind of inferred by the
number of people that were at the studio
and then they sort of clarified that yes
this is what we do we sort of we sort of
take an idea from the ground up kind of
build the framework and whatever and
then maybe partner with somebody to
finish it up
um
so i don't know this sort of in my in my
view being something that's new
maybe we don't quite understand how that
works maybe we don't quite understand
that this is the way it's going to be
with people coming in and out
um
so i'm not going to sit here and be like
this is this and this is that because i
just don't know
what i will say is this
when you have the people at the top of
the food chain
um in all aspects of development leaving
that's worrisome to me because the thing
is if if you're in
if you're in it from the beginning at
the inception of the concept of this
game of bringing back this character
then i feel that if you walk away before
it's done
then you don't really you're not really
invested in either the franchise the
character or the iteration of the
character that you're bringing forward
right it just sort of feels like if you
were there at the inception
and walking away
it just and so many people walking away
that was sort of there at the inception
of this
is what's worrisome to me because at
that point my thinking is why even
bother bringing joanna dark back if it's
going to be a product that's kind of
that doesn't feel like it has a focus
and a heart
and a heart that comes from not just one
person not you know uh daryl gallagher
and that's it you know at the end of the
day by the time this game comes out the
only person left from the initial team
is daryl gallagher is like okay then
what's what's the vision that we're
getting as opposed to the initial vision
of the game okay so for me it
what's what's worrisome is the fact that
it doesn't feel like
whomever is working on this game the
investment in truly bringing perfect
dark back and making it great not good
great because in my opinion this is it
i'm not saying that perfect dark
had has the the burden on its shoulders
that bringing back god of war did or
anything i'm not saying that but at the
same time you're bringing joanna dark
back as a first person shooter on a
platform and an ecosystem that is rife
with first-person shooters great ones at
that
and
if you're not fully committed to making
this game unique and stand out on its
own from the rest of the stuff that's
coming out you feel it's like a lack of
commitment on some level it it just
feels like overall that it feels like
there's a lack of commitment from the
people that kind of initiated this
project and
and that's that's what's worrisome to me
i don't want to sit here and and say
this person leaving is a but when
this last person that left i'm sorry it
was the last person that left was who
again blue burger no i forgot the name
right the game director
the thing about game director is this is
the person that is at the helm or at the
top of people sort of yeah of but
creating basically
the flow the look the feel of the game
that we get as a final product this is
the person that's in charge of putting
those pieces together to make sure it
works well as a singular product and
when that person walks away again it
just feels like where is the commitment
to bringing back this character and this
franchise in this way and like i said
i'm not saying the perfect dark has that
cachet to be frank perfect dark is one
good game right right right
yeah perfect dog zero is what it was
it's not perfect dark is one good game
that if you go back to play it today
probably doesn't hold up here as well
so a lot of it is hey we have this
character that can be very cool bring
her forward modernize her in a way that
redefines her makes her super exciting
for a modern audience and i just don't
with you know people leaving left and
right
it just feels it just feels like the
commitment isn't there and what worries
me is like i've seen conversations and
arguments about well you know people you
know the people are getting offered
three times the amount of money that
they had that they're getting there and
the thing is you're gonna tell me
that microsoft
one of the richest companies
is going to penny pinch now when it
comes to salaries and keeping the top
talent it doesn't yes
yeah i don't see that point right so
the reasons for leaving have to be in my
opinion different than that
that's what worries me i'm not gonna
speculate on you know
the culture and this i'm not gonna do
that i just feel like
i want the commitment the perfect dark
to be there i really do and i don't know
i don't know that i see that there oh
spice off and spicy today attic you up
i actually have a completely different
thought
i think that
this is a power struggle between crystal
dynamics
[Music]
i feel like
daryl might be subconsciously agreeing
to the old studio he used to work for
all those years ago
and i think after a certain amount of
time people feel like they voiced that
being heard i think there might be a
scenario where
there's something might be going on
behind closed doors that we don't know
about they might be on this like you
know if you guys do good on cr on
perfect dart we're gonna buy crystal
dynamics and merge them together and i
think there might be a scenario going on
behind closed doors where a lot of these
people
because if you look at the initiatives
higher ups and crystal dynamics higher
ups i'm sure there's a lot of crossover
right so something like that ever
happened people people are getting let
go or at least getting demoted you can't
have two people doing the same job
so i personally feel like
you're already in the beginning stages
of this so i don't i don't feel like
it's a lot
i don't feel like there's not enough
friction going around to like have
people leave
in the masses like this unless it's
something
critical and what it had and it's recent
it's like the last 12 months of what was
recent crystal dynamics
the timing is very very very similar to
the correlation so
so adam do you think do you think it was
a surprise to the devs that were already
there that they brought crystal dynamics
in like what the hell are you doing like
i don't think that was something that
they never were told was going to happen
like something of that that magnitude i
don't know what
you know daryl gallagher's like mindset
is with something like this uh for all i
know that this is something that he
always wanted
but he had to go through certain links
to get i don't know if like he set out
like you know maybe his mindset's like i
love to work with with my old crew again
and when that possibility came out
she took it and now you got these people
that have similar positions working on
either side of these companies and i
feel like when when you get all these
people in a room all these higher up
people and you got these people that a
lot of them he hand picks to go to the
initiative to
to poach for the initiative and then you
have people over here on crystal
dynamics that he's worked with for years
so i feel like maybe he naturally trusts
crystal oh dynamics a little bit more
and i think maybe he he's agreeing a
little bit too much on one side and not
the other
because when you have these lead people
leave lay people make bags they don't
leave for no reason they leave for toxic
environments or they get better paying
jobs like some said i don't feel like
you're going to lose some of these
people because of money right
you're going to be able to counter them
pretty easily because you can't pay
more than the majority of the people in
this
in the business world in the industry
works so i feel like it's got to be
something more
and the reason i think it's this crystal
dynamics is because this is such a
unique
situation that we've never seen someone
from square enix coming to work yeah i
never see that so to me it feels like
maybe this has already been done like
they just ain't coming up officially the
question the question is why
why is this being done right that it's a
lot going on here it's a good one
gallagher wants his old people working
because he feels more comfortable with
them uh i don't i think that because if
you look at jazz just corn
like
i feel like
things that the initiative are changing
and some
they might they could have done it
better but
it seems like the way direction that the
studio's going is is for the good
now i don't know if people noticed but
look
i don't know why so many people are
leaving it's complete speculation on
terms of if crystal dynamics is having
like this merger at the end of it
because the only reason i'm saying that
is because of how unique the situation
is and like do you go back from working
with microsoft to go right back to
square enix i think that's it's kind of
the latter like right i feel like there
there might be already some kind of
paperwork in place that as long as they
don't mess this up
i honestly feel like crystal dynamics is
going to be bought and they're going to
be merged with the initiative to make
one studio
and
and like
regardless what's happening with that
that's my opinion
i'm going to put like
clearly there's a conversation whether
or not microsoft is having uh you know
some kind of uh management they're
saying they gotta crack the whip
say they got crack i do feel like they
got two to a point with certain studios
but look when you own and i'm
considering activision being bought when
you're on 30 plus studios some people
are going to rebel some people ain't
going to do what they supposed to when
you own this many studios you're going
to have to
constantly
have some of them being put up in the
news for some reason
like people forget how much friction
naughty dog went through before uh last
of us two came out
they lost a lot of their their staff too
that's fact so it just wasn't working on
factions
hey yo
yo you still do
it's just a natural thing that happens
and i honestly feel like this is
something that we this is one of the
situations that we need more information
like we don't know why these people i
got enough information for you
to me like daryl gallagher
is so qualified for that position
this dude has been working everywhere
and and when you take his criteria and
what he's done in the past
if this is going on under his watch
clearly
he he neither co-signed some of these
people probably left without you know
obviously you can't keep people there to
a point but it's just like i'm gonna
trust this dude and obviously perfect
dark come out and bomb that is true okay
come out he will be on notice
all beyond daryl gallagher but to me for
some reason
i'm gonna put my trust in there well i
don't know why but like maybe
what's happening over there at the
initiative
it's just better for the actual studio
they've been out there being a company
for four years and still ain't got
nothing done maybe maybe some of the
people
is the reason maybe somebody maybe
somebody else is cracking the whip
it's gonna be interesting man i can't
get ahead because i'm ready too really
good okay so
the things that we actually do know
let's go
um the original team well first let's
let's
the initiative is an agile
group yes it's going to be small
and agile
they're going to build the framework
and another studio is going to finish
off after they finish whiteboarding
right
so
that leads me to believe a lot of the
workers
are on six months to eight months
contracts
so let's say those guys they leave
now the directions
of where the studios were going
shout out to jazz
dudes wanted to have episodic content
i heard one of the initial visions was
yeah
put your arm down like no like he put
his hand up in the meat and he kept
saying we should do episodic content to
keep the game past thing going no
no we not
see
what mr gallagher knows
is he successfully
brought back tomb raider to prominence
he successfully took a female actually
probably the most iconic female
character in the history of video games
and brought besides miss pac-man
brought her back to prominence without
and removing the sexuality from the
character and giving a deeper
understanding of the character telling a
story right she he actually did
nathan drake it mm-hmm right
so all right so now that he did that he
made tomb raider
relevant this is another female
character
that he has to bring back
that he wants to do it in an iconic way
and it has to go through
the old format it cannot go through
episodic format because he wants to tell
a complete concise story and maybe attic
is on to something maybe there is some
paperwork in the background
and maybe he was getting too much
pushback on individuals that was
probably undermining him while he was
working and said i'm going to go to the
people that i've been in the trenches
with the dudes i bust guns with on the
block
tommy do his job
are you implying that dudes was there a
coup
yeah well you know what happened i told
you that you could go
cool
but i got this question oh oh let's get
his
i feel like there's a power struggle and
chris the dynamic won the power struggle
because they had the dude in the league
let's all get this kind of ball real
quick they get quick it's not
accountable it's just a question it's
like okay
because the people that they were
interviewed right that left yes they
said they made it seem like the norm for
them in other places they worked is that
they could have they could they had
autonomy and their opinions mattered on
every level and it was just a super
collaborative thing is that something
again i don't know what we have you know
i know you've talked to more devs than
than i have you talk like is that
something that's the norm because they
seem to leave if they're leaving the
initiative based on that right right
so is that so archaic what the
initiative is doing or and it's and it's
not being done at the majority of
studios which which part of it you're
asking is being archaic the part of
collaborative part where it's top down
where it's top down well i tell you what
this is
from what i understand shout out to jazz
shout out to um grub
when they were initially formed with the
small and agile part it was like this
different thing like you said this
collaborative yo we're gonna get in the
room and then we'll come up with a base
thing and then we'll outsource it and
yada yada yada and the vibe from the
reports is like i'll join
a felt no
they're making it seem like that is not
the norm like norm now they expect the
expectation wherever they go is that
everything they say is going to be taken
into account right right like it was so
strange
this was what was
told to them right right right okay so
right okay you guys are going to be able
to get in there and you're going to mix
it up yes well obviously y'all wasn't
getting nothing done
how many times your mom's told you go
finish your homework and you sat there
and you was doing everything else and
she had to come in and crack that whip
on that back so you had to figure it out
right
this is that
malcolm said these dudes is talking too
much and i we got deadlines we got
covert stuff we got stuff yo chris dude
because you know what he can count on he
can count on those people that he was on
that block with he can count on those
dudes that he can go home and go to
sleep and know that that paperwork gonna
be done tomorrow is gonna be at his desk
he can he he understands that these
dudes get it done because when he left
it in other people's hands there was um
a but um but um
okay so what um this what happened was
um
nobody want to hear but um and this is
what had happened was all right are you
applying the deadlines was a baby
all we got is the cgi cutscene
and and y'all ain't agile
that's not being asked
you for
the fourth a wasn't kicking in yo and if
and
if
you felt aginus was all right
what we're going to do is give you
bite-sized chunks of a whole complete
game
y'all can say hell no you ain't putting
my name on that
let's do something different and then
you come back to the meeting again the
next day well how about we do bite-sized
chunks smaller portions he said in a
different way
smaller portions
right
no how about we do the whole game
okay
how about we do episodic all right you
gotta go
he had to know
the
big dg's in the building big town i'm
tired of you trying to give me the same
thing that all over but telling me it
differently king but
here's the thing right i'll just play i
don't have to get i know where you're
going but but this is mad people on the
ceo it i could understand if it was just
one right so they thought they was going
to rock the boat
so you think you're going with the cool
that's what you're going with i they
thought gallagher was there for play
play
like they thought that he was their
friend you know how many times do you
got an employee
that thinks he's your friend but you the
boss like
at that when when i have to cut the
strings i'm gonna cut it he's gonna look
over at you like oh he was friends
so this is
they thought it was sweet with dg we
gonna call them big dg right so they
thought it was they thought dg was a
player
so
i just say this the same
he has the pedigree
all right and listen
avengers
wasn't a failed game it was a failed
game as a service service but the game
the story story was fire it was lit
graphics
guardian of the galaxy story is lit so
let's not act like crystal dynamics is
out here
all right so they they actually giving
you high quality stuff
story driven narrative
what gallagher is trying to get to right
these other dudes y'all okay we hear
y'all left that episodic stuff ain't
ain't sitting right with me and if
there's smoke there's fire so if one
dude gonna say
i don't want this let's let's okay a lot
all right so how about we do a story
and we complete it and we give it to
them and they say okay and they come
back tomorrow with something else
it's not working here and he has to talk
to his bosses so when matt booty comes
in and say okay so let me see what you
got when we act with this
okay so
progress be there right they all sitting
in a room and probably daryl was inside
the back and they like okay so what we
was thinking about was this episodic
didn't i tell you don't say that again
[Laughter]
why the episodic was the downfall
so i kept saying that to me
you can't come back around here no more
we you we have a conflict it's not we
don't want a bid to keep you
if they want you they can have you
because right now we're looking for
something and you're not giving us that
well and it's cool because when
other developers leave or other heads of
manager management leave other companies
i'm in an uproar saying all types of
stuff is doom and gloom all right so
when these dudes are saying that i
understand but remember i don't play for
your team i play for mine i'm the xbox
offense force and i'm here for that i'll
go for you okay
i gotta get my balls off i'll be patient
the thing is the thing is king the
reason i feel like
it's it's it's the crystal dynamics
thing is because there's so many high
people leaving get one or two that's one
thing but when you have a whole lot
leaving usually it's something else
because you don't have this many people
leaving a certain amount of time that's
what i feel like one of the only
scenarios obviously could be a variety
of different things is
they're scared their job is going to get
to it like i said if you merge crystal
dynamics in the initiative there's going
to be there's going to be a lot of jobs
overlap yeah overlap
and to me
some of the people they initiative might
feel like daryl if this will happen this
is complete speculation
but if this something like this were to
happen they might feel like yo he
picking his people
listen let me get these off let me get
these this is fun i like i cannot wait
to see what happens with this hitch this
is the most intriguing situation i have
ever seen
um off rip what i my initial
feeling of it
my strongest number one feeling about
this is
the big dg
got a lot of power in that building
yeah daryl gallagher
for like when we first heard the news
that crystal dynamics was coming on we
were like wow that's interesting like
squared up first of all square let that
go right so that's one aspect of like yo
you ain't doing and we'll take a bag to
throw you over there on another you know
xbox game suit that like i've never seen
that right then never happens you've got
a guy who's in a head right ahead of a
studio
who got all these connections in another
building to get a whole studio to come
work on your game that you've had these
years and years relationship with right
so that was just interesting in itself i
did some little research on mr gallagher
okay look at this resume
call of duty modern warfare water
welfare 2 infinite destiny 2 2017.
he was a senior vet senior vice
president had a development at
activision crash bandicoot skylanders
danny before that square enix he was
there he did rise in a tomb raider 20
year anniversary hitman deus ex human
revolution just cause laura croft life
is strange hitman rise of the two mural
laura croft and the temple of osiris
thief then he was that crystal dynamics
before that 10 years head of studio tomb
raider tomb raider trilogy director of
art tomb raider um anniversary legend he
was at thq
he's a lead position lead artist at
rockstar head of creative at saudi this
is his resume
all i'm saying is this
this man trusted
is here's the resume that he got i'm not
disrespecting anybody i'm not just
making anybody that left they all got
resumed but this resume is impressive
like to have all these titles in lead
positions everywhere you went right so
i'm again i don't know what's going on
in the building completely right but
i can assume based on what we see in it
i can make an educated guess based on
the information that is currently
presented that it feels in big corporate
right
you could start off with an initial
vision and you highlight yo i'm going to
apply for this job on linkedin because
you we're going to collaborate and we're
going to do this and then it's going to
be small and agile and then as the
project goes on and maybe to king's
point either deliverables ain't met or
like we would kind of imply what's at
explain like there might maybe there is
a cool and let me explain this we had
all mark dara from bioware right and one
of the things he's playing on defining
duke was that
usually the top guys at a big company
they know what the core vision of the
game is
right then has it trickled down as it
disseminates dudes being pocketed big
corp not everybody's talking to each
other every day everybody's working on
their little specific thing right so if
you got guys that are not i'm not saying
not listening but are not
focusing on what his vision may have
been
then he may come back okay what's the
progress on where we at
and if there's no progress they're like
oh these dudes ain't listening or the
flip side where the guy's not like oh he
wants us to do this but we was promised
that this was going to be collaborative
and we wanted the direction of perfect
thought should be this way right and
then they get together and then remember
they senior level guys they form a cool
like nah perfect dog we want the
episodic or whatever i'm just making
stuff up like we want whatever and
that's the fight so then you get that
big meeting or maybe microsoft it comes
in and wait what's the status of perky
dark guys and daryl's like this is that
it's a perfect dark yeah yeah
like how we do it guys
like look
you know
things ain't where i want it to be can
you sit down right and because i always
find it weird that the timing of these
departures coincide with crystal
dynamics to me if crystal dynamics comes
in in my opinion that is to facilitate
this man's vision
they know how he work what you call a
cake they've been on the block together
they've produced hits mega hits i'm
gonna get my people because y'all not
listening right that's it
i'm just i'm theorizing i'm theorizing
right that could be what's in there
right and he could come and then they go
oh how dare you like this is not what
was promised to me you told me
collaboration right it could be just
something as simple as
daryl and the initiative the other
people at the initiative had a vision
right that they wanted to and then
crystal dynamics came there to make it
and there they pulled daryl's side like
have you seen this but but yeah it could
be that we need a chase or it could be
that you get again i just i don't think
crystal dynamics came over and and
started the beef that's what i don't
think i think i think he's so i think he
saw something
it was like oh hell no you're not
listening yeah listen his resume his
resume is no duds right
so he said oh hell no i'm going to put
my name in that yeah oh no no no oh no
no oh crystal
hey but here's the gangster pocket
how he got enough power as a head of a
studio to make a you don't get it
crystallized
you have to pay bread to get crystal in
it and that means microsoft is show
facts but in my opinion i've never that
means low key unless there's something i
don't know where a studio head could go
get
another studio to come in
and and someone's fitting that bill is
what i'm saying soft someone's paying
for that okay so he goes like this right
yeah he pulls mac booty over because i
ain't gonna get feeling this
ain't gonna get [ __ ] up
phil's doing something else all right
matt matt come here come here man
look at this
look at this matt and he said well
what's going on i thought we had agreed
matt
what are we going to do because we know
we can't go tell phil wow
how we're going to get this done he said
you're listening i got an idea
i got my old group over there they're
not doing nothing and he know that
they're not doing nothing
right now they've been put on the
sidelines and they've been shouted out
because they messed up disney's back
that's why they got reprimanded because
you know disney felt that they messed up
their bag they made up promises yeah
they wanted destiny for marvel good
right and then you know matt booty king
was like you know what you're right hey
let's just buy them too
what he said was all right i'm gonna
bring it over the side to you i'm
showing him this when you show me
and i'm gonna tell him we can't have his
this loss satya right now is on a high
game pass is doing good xbox is in a
different space he he's willing to
purchase stuff
okay he'll get them over here
let's go let's go let's go see ain't
gonna hurt to try yo inside there
yeah um come in sit down
look at what they was doing
why are you telling all the boys
you know you know how you see them
behind the glass in the room and they
all looking at you
and their mouths is moving but you don't
know what they're saying
that i can't 100
stand on that
is the boss can't say look what they do
oh the boss can't so say it because he's
in charge of them i give you a job to do
and you don't do it
right and i got a report to the other
dude that's above me
i definitely could say look what i told
this is the finger you see when
something's happening this is the finger
and it's always close to the chest
and you're like that one right there
so i know for a fact
all those people this is great i was
actually leaving they were leaving
because they was like i'm not being hurt
like i had accepted they weren't being
hurt their hand wasn't being raised
because every time you called on them
they gave you the wrong answer to the
question and you stopped calling on them
inside the meeting so people sit there
i feel like when it comes to this i
don't necessarily think it they weren't
doing their job
i just feel like there was there was
conflict on the direction of the game
after crystal dynamics was put into the
fold like i feel like i i disagree only
on the timing i agree what you're saying
i just think you know i don't i don't
think it happened after but okay i'll
let you continue
i i feel like once once daryl
got people all everyone in the same room
i think there was just a lot of light of
you know
debating on the direction of the game
because clearly
could they say see the reason i feel
like that too is they they say that
they're going to do a soft reboot yeah
so why would you do a soft reboot if you
knew the direction of the game before
this happened
if it's like another studio came in
there and didn't like the direction that
they were going to develop the game
i hope that's soft reboot encompasses
them turn them turning it into a third
person
[Applause]
let's be real games that's the kind of
games they make and that is that's what
worried me about crystal dynamics
involvement from the beginning it was
like when you look at crystal dynamics
as pedigree right if their lead on this
they've made one fps point solved
good catch good catch good catch that's
project snow blind yeah 2 000 good catch
listen man i'm rolling with big ddg i
want jack-jack just like
yo listen i want just one i got this
thing and i think you're gonna
understand what i'm talking about here
how many times
does the workers think they know more
than the boss
and these are senior people too with a
lot of success yeah and i'm gonna tell
you what a lot of i'm gonna tell you
something you have a lot of clout
themselves
these are the dudes those are the dudes
that's going possible
yo yo you you're gonna understand what
i'm saying right here [ __ ] teddy on the
dock
teddy on the dock old school girl yup
garoppolo
all these incumbent dudes just sitting
there yeah i know man i know what he
said but do it like this
because they see it and they got got
them on their resume they got resumes
too
right so so this and they tell me i go
there
the boss told me when i strip and wax
the floor to strip and wax in this
fashion yes
sav knows what i'm talking about
teddy on the dock
yeah
don't listen to him you know
and the young boy started listening to
them dudes and listen and you followed
the direction of this dude and then the
boss came
downstairs while you in the middle of
doing what you were doing
didn't i tell you
to strip this first then do this
and then you looking at him but teddy
has said
yeah that was crazy in a matter of 30
minutes we have invented like eight
different ways oh this is great this is
what speculation is
what i'm telling you i know somebody
thought they knew more than gallagher
and he not there whoever that was that's
what i feel not there anymore that's
what i think that is one of the issues
when you get so many high up people
yeah and listen
and that to me again shout out to
bardara for byway he had
he had great point about gamedev and
some of the reasons why they went wrong
with bioware or certain things he said
sometimes you just need that small group
that knows the vision of the game right
and that he said the key is making sure
that that vision is properly
disseminated and everyone is on board
with that so sometimes bigger is not
better in this case they may have had
the small group because it wasn't like
super super big right but to king's
point if you have a bunch of senior
people right
who have success
the guys that left are not some new
jacks on the scene yep these are the
instruments they've been in they got
resumed so to them it's like yo this is
not either a what you promise or b we
don't like what this direction is and
they got enough clout to be like yo we
out so to me when you got a cool or some
type of disagreement they're like the
knights of the realm yeah so then to me
the biggest power move in my opinion is
someone say oh word get crystal on the
phone these dudes don't know what you
know what i'm saying
power if you you are a new studio you're
a brand new i've never heard of a brand
new studio saying what y'all not okay
crystal but you know how we did it back
you know ailmatic we got reasonable
doubt we got ready to die we got you
upset we got two pocket albums on our
joint you know what i'm saying so
putting ours in the booth hey you bro
you see the crystal dynamics people
coming to build it at it
[Applause]
executive people that he just comes in
his office you know the office on the
side he's like yeah i'm gonna put a desk
right here now this is my own
i'm gonna tell you what this is i'm
gonna tell you what this is cod
this is when the rizzo went out of the
grave digging
and then he was like y'all never want to
do it like how i say yo and then
director i am such a such what's your
name yeah i see your day game director
for christian
yo how you got my title imagine imagine
like the conversation that the
initiative had before it was at before
they were told like imagine like like
obviously they were told before they
showed up but imagine if you're just
sitting there
and you're eating your
cheetos it's a nuisance in front he's
like yo i ain't never seen you before
crystal dynamics he's like what he's
like i'm the lead on the art director
and then he just i think he's got like
cheetos in his mouth
what if they come in but they all got
crystal d-shirts
there's a team of dudes with crystal
d-shirts coming to the meeting bro i'll
be mad too i'll be like nah son i ain't
rocking with this christmas
story we gotta take the story a little
farther all right so they got the
crystal t-shirts on the front they got a
picture of the person they replaced it
on there you know that's disrespectful
but i feel you
all i'm saying
[Music]
one of these individuals
[Laughter]
they have like those little micro things
that it has like a mask on it and he
turns around and they rip it off listen
bro
big dg move different i'm learning about
the power of this man and all i will say
is look
this game do got a hit though for all
this this game got a hit but i will say
this they got a lot swirling around it's
got lots
i will say though if he if this game
comes out
after all this the controversy leaves
exit and it is fire
he's going to go down in legend because
people going to remember this day
because don't don't think that there's a
lot of people that left that's hoping
that it failed or hoping that because
they're going to be like oh you know
what corey
yes that's how to he
was so nervous when the reviews launched
because he honestly didn't know how
they're how he's gonna play and remember
when corey went through the building
would remember no jump but he's like
how's the god word with no jump button
how's it what's this little guy why are
you forcing this song but he fought for
that vision for god of war he fought for
it and everybody was not on point and
there were leaves and they were
departures with that and sony up top
remember they rejected a couple of he
fought to keep his job was online so all
we'll say is this and we see where corey
barlow is now daryl gallagher watch
raising cradles yes
if daryl gallagher pulls this off he
will go down in xbox history as a studio
head with a direction and make a classic
and they may have one of them joints
he's got to pull it off he's unlocked
the actual funding for a quadruple yeah
i mean the fact that he got crystal d in
the building already to me is like bro
you moving crazy out here like you can
do what you want so it this is fun i i
want to see what happens this is one of
the story i was the most excited for
this topic
facts but turn it into a third person
game please
listen i am going to be team gallagher
yes hit the like button 600 hit that
like button share like listen um when we
get to um
what is it uh 15. let's get it to 300
and king will do cartwheels and don't
listen to him
in my life
when i was younger i ain't doing a cut
wheel now and that's when i was skinny
and bad yeah just breathe
breathe and visualize you doing the car
listen this is when i was skinny and
agile
i have to call in crystal d to do that
call well listen shout out to geeky
though he said gotta what went back to
the drawbar they didn't bring kick or
dick christine but the same principle
remains the same geeky there which is
there was a soft reboot right there's a
reboot of the thing so at the end of the
day the principle is the same i know
it's not exactly apples to apples but
it'll be interesting to see what happens
man like i'm curious i'm front row for
this drama this is great it's like the
chat said like look there's probably
going to be a soft reboot like most
likely but it's not going to be it's not
all dooms day because these people left
probably about what it was like 20
20 people yeah but crystal the entire
entity of crystal doesn't they're huge
oh they're huge
we staging a walkout they walked out and
crystal d-rings
[Music]
oh the replacement workers came in i got
another one crystal dynamics so you know
they in the room they they say we
shouldn't be treated this way they
trying to like orchestrate a strike and
then they got everyone they didn't like
in a room they got them all to leave and
they shut the door locked change the
access code bring it crystal yo this is
some correct y'all daryl dg man
not working
that's the worst thing you heard at
corporate that's the worst thing you can
hear at corporate it's about
yo i'm swiping like hell
i don't know my strip looks fine my
strip looks good
i can't yeah we bugging you
you just have the person he took his job
screen for the top mine works oh man you
walk straight past me you see crystal
knee walkway pass
i'm done i'm done moving on we messy
this is a great one he tries to go in
the building and secure he just comes in
front looks like that's like
you
all this is a legend allegedly that's
all we do we just speculate yo that's
all that's what we do
just stopping by and showing support
thank you brother
then we have a tyson viewer joe eight
dollar super chat most of the developers
that left are jim ryan's covert spies
now they're back in playstation studios
with knowledge to make world-class games
like a good analogy
if someone if
a car brings someone on sound just like
you
don't worry about it
that was like that the whole thing with
um what's his name with troy baker and
yes and the and the the nft thing is
like yeah you know i'm going to support
these people that are just going to
mimic my voice and just
pay to sound like they can pay some pace
of money to to have some computerized
places
the fact that he had demon deck though
that is crazy to me
that's funny that is yeah we had a
parachute just in case you act in case
yeah but it's like the paris she was
open already
he jumped out
yeah it's like it's like they did the
jump with you just in case and they just
they cut your shoe on the way down like
you out cool
this is the wildest story bro you see on
the channel news tragic story
it's gonna be funny how this plays out
yeah then we got the wise old gamer five
dollar super chat i heard the initiative
is losing so many people that the un has
officially classified it as a
humanitarian crisis
oh my god you're out of control sir
then we got looneyboy 221.
the work that all those devs who left
the initiative did not get erased when
they left they did the work it would be
alarming if those devs left and crystal
dynamics wasn't there the game what if
he finished by a full team
with you and get out
yeah
you're saying that like it's a fact i
don't know about that bro like i got all
your stuff and get all your stuff out
your cubicle and go
okay
then we got kendrick starr two dollars
super chat cyberpunk fps tomb raider
perfect dog will be good fingers crossed
let's see we'll see
that we got sharon kingdom two dollar
super chat galaga out here like kanye i
want my wife back
then we got clutch man 20 super chat how
many didn't watch jez's checkpoint video
about the latest the latest xbox two
jumped right in on the worrying and
concerned hype the moment he said he
heard some of the other side of the
story and wasn't worried this wasn't an
issue yeah i didn't listen to jesus
thing i don't like my opinions being
being
if i listen to jesus stuff all of a
sudden my opinion has changed and again
afterwards now i will go and research
everything i'll just give you the short
of it jazz pretty much thinks
um this is for the good of the game he
feels that he spoke to the group that um
has i guess has remained or whatever and
that yeah like he just feels that at the
end of the day like there was a vision
you know the small
small agile kind of thing it's changed
and
he overall feels it's a positive move
that that
jazz was talking to them you talked to
them on the phone they hung up the phone
and they put the camera pans out it
shows the crystal d on the chest
the fact we thought they had their so i
know that was funny
[Laughter]
the way we was talking about it kind of
reminds me of um that show that was on
netflix recently
it was the one where people had to fight
over like all that money
yeah they had the shirts all moving
somebody had the answers to the tests
already
this is clatt this is classic us though
this is speculation and creating stories
and doing stuff this is vintage
this is why we exist 60 people walking
with the crystals
they turn they turn face the doors start
coming at you like an army listen man
they
after tasting his new chick
gallagher wants his old chick back and
asked microsoft to fund the bag to bring
her back to him how bad was the fish
smell down jesus
wow
jesus what's their old gamer please
children are watching the day
so crystal the ride or so crystal is the
right of that chick
yes
facto facto he called up the old thing
it was like we going to do this how we
do this i honestly believe
when in doubt
cd your way out
bro it just showed me how much power
that man got i've never seen it look at
that now matt booty was on you know
first of all
let's give a shout out to matt booty
because the man moves in silence and
carries a big stick pulse like
these studios is is humming along
they're doing everything that they're
doing and anything that we've just heard
of we just heard of this stuff right
here right and it seems like this
problem got rectified and cleaned up
very quick before uh uh a game of bad
game could come out a game that is too
much trouble going on you hear
these guys left but there's replacements
there on deck
right so this is unheard of and the fact
that let's be honest microsoft unless
daryl gallagher gotta hold his own
separate bag to buy crystal dynamics i
would assume i would assume that he got
some connection to get microsoft to make
this this move because that was that
square took a bag to give up you got to
say that's matt you know because
remember matt booty's in charge of those
situations yeah so remember he reports
directly to my booty booty
but think about matt booty even allowing
daryl gallagher to do that like think
about like dao gal got to be so much in
the building for them to even listen and
sign off so you know what daryl yeah all
right we got you i think when you go and
get a daryl gallagher
his opinion and his voice is her yes
that's what it showed me that's going to
show me i i completely agree good to see
you soon
all right then we got shiron kingdom two
dollars no we got that one already we
got looney boy 221
no one should be concerned about the
initiative literally three months after
phil bought in brought in chris dynamics
he convinced sachin nadella to spend 69
billion to buy activision blizzard then
gets promoted to ceo of gaming relax
that's fine but that has nothing to do
with it
that's great but that's great but you
know
let's do it then we got loony boy again
2000 chat phil said we're done building
studios we buying them that's true no
that's true we told dudes before anyway
they're getting
uh producers people that can actually
see a game from the beginning to
conception to actually ship yeah
stop trying to make it seem like perfect
dark will be better in third person it's
a first person franchise
it's a it's essentially one game it's
like it's a franchise perfect
the perfect dark zero blow up the world
was it so amazing like come on you're
right too because
um
god of war was a really isometric uh
cinematic type of game remember it was
type top down you know it was literally
the jack and daxter engine right so
come on guys don't act like it hasn't
been done uh no but you know what's
funny too is also like people have to
understand game development is difficult
man
it's difficult and a lot of our favorite
games the thing is sony has done a good
job at understood have a good job
what it is let's be honest microsoft in
my opinion a lot of stuff they got a lot
of leaks in the building in my opinion
because you don't hear about these
stories but the thing is we know they
exist because when we hear that jason
schneiderlin
about days going on
yeah so what it goes to show me there
are so many other studios that go
through
turmoil and changes and soft reboots and
things like that but sometimes the story
doesn't get out so we just assume oh
everything is just structured it's the
foundation's great and it's smooth over
there and and everything over here like
it's always just wild and crazy you know
since you know what it is
it's the pedigree of so much right and
and to your point king this is where
you're right and what i said on define
and do with maddie
the problem with microsoft with the
situation is until the games from their
first party outside of forza here
they come out and they have that level
of cachet then the talk about
mismanagement and doom and gloom is
going to stop you know saying they just
got it so like initiative got to hit
right this guy if they once they do that
and these are critically acclaimed games
then people will get off the back so i
understand the concern is is legitimate
but okay yeah but i'm just saying you
can look at
what happened with um
the last of us too right all that stuff
swirling around but it's still hit it
hit right that's all that matters
and that's the only thing that matters
sony stuck by their guns
stuff still hit whatever was going on
there same thing we got a wall yeah
these games hit so
microsoft this has to hit this has to
hit can't come out yes and b
and if they choose to go and take it
from first person and do like horizon
like gorilla games it was a first person
studio take it off of that and just go
to a third person type game i think
honestly
remove it from first person i mean but
in my opinion that's a big move too many
that's a big it is it is a big move when
you have that much competition in-house
greatest first-person shooters ever
it's time
perfect dark was amazing for its time go
back and play perfect dark now
it was amazing because they lost the um
james bond license the golden yeah the
golden eye license and now they were
doing their first only game and it
actually stood up to close to golden eye
so that's why it was all dope yeah shout
out to my boy oh one bad mother shout
out from xbox eras look you guys you got
that fill on and all that he said some
of the greatest games of all time went
through hell and major changes mid
development cycle end of the day it's
all about the final product that's the
scoreboard it's a fact though because
the game hit all this we talked about
six or yeah yeah yeah it don't mean
nothing
and that's another thing that's why
that's why part of my points were like i
don't even want to speculate what's
going on the thing about it is you know
every
all of gaming is an s show it always is
like it doesn't matter the game it
doesn't matter the level of talent or
experience of of the of the of the
studio
you ask anybody every game is different
and every game is just a is a nightmare
up until it's not yeah
and probably it's not when it's done
yeah and that's
it's just what it is
yeah it's it's a difficult business
sometimes things
this studio is making a like it's from
scratch
taking over in the current existence
studio like it's literally from scratch
yep just got to land the play and
execute then all the talk goes out good
diggers up
all right
let's see
hold on a second we have a whole bunch
oh my god
uh
so yeah donald trump for this it's a
first person franchise and it should
stay that way i i disagree anyway the
yzo gamer 5 super chat david
darryl david g
daryl david g
yeah i had daryl g to crystal d uh i
like that do it again
next time mama girl bring your
work with it go to work with it
back work with it
i'm done i am done with your base right
now
the face man is educating our children i
hope you didn't
it's the kids listen to him
the wise old gamer wants to get five
dollars super chat so what you're saying
is that gallagher is like my wife when
she wants to finish her job she also
pulls out the crystal
whoa my god
jesus
move it on he's so loose pragmatic eagle
remember for 29 months thank you
pragmatic good thank you i'm a little in
shock after that last night
nothing shocks
me that was the funniest speculation of
a potential problem
would have posted something like that
yeah that was definitely left
that's very well being oh my god
let's go and there's no no potential
problems here pac-man this is all facts
all we talk about is facts
and we've got hard geeks in the five
dollars super chat salute to the lords
hogwarts star field if breath of the
wild 2 comes out man what a year maybe
ps fans will even get right
then we got jd gamer member for 24
months jd thank you my brother
all this happens because the game
industry is still mistrusting of
microsoft because it's only a story it's
because it's only a story because it's
an xbox studio
i mean
it's a lot of movement like there's a
lot of movement like nobody's not going
to notice that right he had the same
stuff when it was sony stuff so when
people move from over there people say
the same things we are just more
cognizant we hear it more if that's
their platform of choice
yeah um then we got strong kingdom two
dollar super chat
so booty dropped it low to get the back
wow don't we talk about booty dropping
anything
i don't like the kind of thing we're
never getting anyone else on the show
yeah
we got
also had third person elements and
that's why it was trash the game was
just trash it's not the third person
elements it just made yeah i thought now
decent and the game wasn't okay yeah i
don't like using the word trash there
was parts of it they were decent it
definitely didn't live up to the
pedigree of the first one right and as a
launch game i was just like i'm gonna go
play call of duty 2 and i'm going to go
play condemned instead of this
oh you remember condemn no oh i love
canada yeah so it just wasn't up to
snuff um
hold on we got jumped a little bit oh
miles don't pay what's going on lois
shout out to you man should i listen to
uh you and jazz on this was it countdown
or check that what's the name of that
show
yeah a little two-man check down yeah i
called that shot the miles down p.a in
the realm talking that nice speculation
talk
no doubt then we got jd gamer 10 super
chat when are we going to stop using
double standards to judge xbox versus
playstation no one is worried when
playstation studios losing staff right
left and center
thing is jd gamer until they start
making games that will result in these
people
reflect that
i mean let's not forget there was a lot
of talk around
um what the hell is a motorcycle game um
oh day's long day's going dave's gone i
mean they
they didn't get away with that you know
what i mean like there was a there was a
lot of talk about it you can't you know
and he's talking about the last topic
he's going to talk about stuff
the worm has turned
there we go
jd gave her once again five dollars
playstation studio devs have been
running the microsoft studios
all are they all doomed because
microsoft has taken more depth from them
than than a glass joe takes then a glass
joe takes hits in a fight whoa but again
i mean this is all again all of them are
in santa monica i think right or
whatever they are they
that it's like
yeah they all kind of work with each
other they go they jump from bed to bed
that's the nature of the yeah it's true
it's just true you know they talk to
each other they like yo i have an
opening over here they jump from studio
to studio everybody know each other
yeah they know each other like they go
to lunch they see each other at the same
food trucks you see how it is and
they're like yo what you're doing over
there like all the companies is it a
roundabout circle
you know
all those stuff is like right there
so yeah you know when you go to lunch
and you you're seeing people oh yo you
know what y'all work you know what you
talking about
yo i gotta open it over here you wanna
hang out
i think you dope i'm i'm gonna switch my
job and hang out what's the pain what's
the pain
that's what they talking about i think i
could get you an extra hundred
kills
i mean i get it let me see gamer by
choice five dollar super chat iop should
be a syndicated comedy show you are all
awesome thank you so much
we got christopher hart two dollars of a
chat today's podcast deserves a big
pause emoji
[Music]
[Laughter]
outside little round table review little
action you know what i'm saying
made for the wanderers developers diary
so i want to shout out hold on i gotta
shout out the home team right quick lord
to gaming.net great article up right now
steve perry salute got argued five new
things we learned about star field you
know i mean so pretty much he was out
there so basically kind of the tenants
were like one was like the focus on
emerging
the studio has a long gamepl of building
games where developers narrative takes a
back seat to the stories players create
so it seems that starfield is going
poised to continue that direction second
tenet was building characters with a
history so just talk about the you know
the deep rkr rpg mechanics things of
that nature
specifically god howard expressed
enthusiasm for the opportunity to revive
some well-liked features of classic rpg
character creation he says in star field
players can go around with the
backgrounds to traits defining your
character all those stats and they'll go
their goal for those defining aspects is
that they will continue to ground your
character's history then another tenant
was the new technology that they're
using for character models so that i
thought that was interesting to make it
a reality but that's the use of
technology similar to photo grammar i
can't pronounce that dramatic
grammatical grammatical
okay there we go creating in-game assets
using multiple photos of real objects
which helped them create believable mpc
models thought that was interesting
based on the fact that you know let's be
honest creation engine does get some
flack from back in the day you know and
all that um they talk about a new
persuasion system and it kind of makes
all elude alluded to um oblivion what
happened some jedi those are not the
droids you're looking at
they said why did they give it too much
you stupid he said if you he said um my
boy says you can make some guesses shout
out to steve he said um if you have a
high enough speech that in a game like
skyrim you will automatically pass any
persuasion check check but in contrast
in oblivion which they think it might be
closer to persuading the npc requires
succeeding in a mini-game and involves
some level of attention and detail to
the story and social awareness by the
players so he said that um they want the
players to feel a sense of risk in
social and characters they don't want to
feel that the player has there's a
definite right thing to say and the last
thing we know about is the factions they
got like three factions united colonies
they said those are
this group either idealize space
republic they may fit for lawful good
characters who want to make the world of
skyrim part of their structured society
then there's the free star collective
they're like a frontiersman space
western fantasy and that those that will
probably that fracture will attract
those who want their character starfield
to be an explorer discovering new lands
and planets on the frontiers of space
then you have raijin industries those
the corporate dudes interests and
lifestyle you know what i'm saying want
to turn the galaxy into profit like king
and uh last one will be the crimson
fleet and those are the space prizes
pirates they run around maybe a little
bit of antagonistic you know what i'm
saying but um they said even good
characters could enjoy that but look a
lot of information a lot of stuff i want
to say hey what you guys feel about it
and then two the controversy which is
you know some people like yo
well that's nice
where the game play though
[Laughter]
so let's get into it let's start with
attic man star field how excited not
excited are you in is the gameplay thing
i know actually that was one thing you
said that uh i believe that um
e3 last e3 thing you know i know you
were concerned about that so what yeah
with everything man
uh
look i i here here's how they here's how
they normally do stuff now the only
thing that makes this different is they
kind of jump the gum but they don't
normally do it on announcing the initial
game they announced that in elder
scrolls 6 in 2018 they don't normally do
that right and that that's why people
were upset because it's been all these
years without seeing nothing
but it's just like my standpoint it's
like that's why i wanted to see it last
year because i was kind of expecting a
release date last year right but now
that we're getting it this year normally
the way they do things is though now
it's a game and then a couple months
later they'll show game play and then
like four months later after that the
game comes out yep uh the only
difference is the first part they
announced it years ahead of time yes
that was the different part i feel like
the reason they did that is because
bethesda themselves might not have been
in a good time like in the public view
at that time so maybe they jumped a gun
to get good grace like look we got
starfield coming we got elder scrolls
six coming we got stuff coming because
at the end of the day people love the
other stuff that they used to publish
but people love their stuff and that we
just wasn't getting a lot of their stuff
right now
as far as like what we see on the game
when you read that
it screams we're going back to our roots
yeah it screams that we want to make
sure that you have actual dialogue like
when i read that and it's like we want
to make sure that there's not a
a a right or wrong choice it kind of
reminds me of something like mass effect
something like dragon age where it's
like at any time you think something
might be the right thing but then you
could panic they feeling it and he just
starts attacking
so you know that's the kind of dialogue
that they have in this game like
obviously they didn't make fallout new
vegas but
you could play a lot of that game
without even fighting if you get your
speech up high enough right you're the
last boss in the game you can literally
talk him in to disarming himself
so it's just like that's what makes
these type of games and they kind of
went away from fallout 4. i've always
said that fallout 4 is a good game but
not a good fallout game kind of like how
i said um you know the breath of the
wild is a good game but not a good zelda
game and it's because both games kind of
went away from the core but the
foundation of of their games were made
off because what i like to as i see i
see on here i see a studio that seeing
games like witcher take they take these
snacks
seeing games like uh uh you know bioware
at their height when they were going
through this taking their snacks and now
they're like look
they're taking the stacks
like
because if you look at it they haven't
won a game of the year since skyrim
and
if you look at that before that they i
think they won't fall out three they won
skyrim i'm pretty sure they won
morrowind so it's just like this
it's it's an arguably debatable thing
that people was always saying like in
the rest of their games i want to add it
was
contenders it wasn't like facts in there
every time this studio has made a game
it's been the talk of the year
and most of the time they can end up
leaving with the best game of the year
and that's that's the whole thing when
it comes to it's like look like much
girl said they said fall off for one
game of the year i'm pretty sure dragon
age won okay okay this is the game that
came out it might have been um witcher
3. what came out did what's your three
come out there i don't know people in
there it's probably what you're throwing
for the chat
the chat is saying fallout 4 one game of
the year they did they just say i don't
remember did it i can't i need pretty
sure that it got beat by something else
because there was a lot of debate going
on about that i don't know that's
besides the fact yeah uh the fact is
this is witcher 3.
yeah you see i see chad you trying to
act like you know more than me
like look like
when it comes to
what they did like i like the factions
seems like they're really putting
factions to a core i love factions that
are done right uh once again fallout new
vegas said no they didn't make this game
but you know you can't just roll up into
the ncr
like like yeah being part of the the
legion guild
the legion crew because the ncr will
shoot you on site that's what i want in
this game i want stats they they really
emphasize that they're bringing stats
back
and if you guys remember i was
disappointed with fallout 4 didn't have
stats it didn't have dialogue but then
when you look at something like the
obsidian making the outer world it had
all of that yeah so it's just like
what'd you think oh oh we lost him we
lost him
he's frozen
everything good everything good let me
see now we
a game that they that they've not seen
game play for and what i would say on
that is don't don't hype it
but where you lose me is where you
attack people that generate hype for
that game yes people have no problem
hyping up games like naughty dog rock
star and what's funny bethesda has more
game of the years than these other
studios
but it's okay to hype them up but you
can't hype up this game so are you
implying that there's a pedigree
associated with but does it that that
would i just feel like there's a natural
hatred towards bethesda
i feel like people
because they they do generally
yeah they make both broken games they
make very bugs and they win game of the
year with the broken
yeah you see that's how that's what i
gotta
that they're coming out busted not
busted they're they're functionable they
just
sometimes like it's good it's like
you know it's like the fcc you can eat a
little bit of rat pool
there's a little bit just it's a little
bit of rapport
i didn't know that was real at the end
of the day
if you don't want to hype up this game
don't hype it up but don't attack people
that don't that that are excited for
that i'd play fallout new vegas i got
like 800 hours
i played fallout 3 i got like four or
500 hours
i played
i played fallout 4 even though i didn't
like it more than the other one i got
like three 400 i remember being like
being in my teens switching between
runescape and morrowind
like i've been around this franchise for
for decades like it's just like you know
the crazy part about it is just like
stop being
the the height police like but but what
but some of the hype police
no they they coming out there like like
he mad at me
yeah and i get it we don't know what it
is but we we don't know what a lot of
games are what people were hyping up
death training and we had no idea what
that game i wasn't hyping that game up
at all especially when i saw here had
book bags and stuff and
i like oh no i get it people people like
to use this narrative that oh but attic
they may fall at 76. they help with that
game they're not that's not the 18th
studio that's that game that's nothing
like people need that's like equivalent
to attacking
like i'm naughty dog helps a bunch of
studios
are we going to start attacking their
their games because it because naughty
dog helped them yeah so oh oh hold on we
got bt in the chat hold on he's what he
wanted to made the track to see the
video he said i love being the hype
police
[Laughter]
how about you pull up
yeah because he's definitely on the
other side of this argument he's
definitely on the other side for you
[Music]
let's get your balls off too man what
you think like oh first of all are you i
haven't talked to you about your
excitement or non-excitement of
starfield so i'm curious
i mean i'm excited for i mean this is
their first new ip and like damn day at
30 yes yeah it's like
it's kind of bonkers right so i'm
excited for to see the lessons that
they've learned yeah and and to really
look at the gaming landscape now to see
the games we have out here
and to know that the expectation is from
a lot of people is that they're going to
match or one-up those games in some way
shape or form it's just facts it's just
facts
like
it it can't be the same old it cannot be
this skyrim just skyrim in space
can't
i don't know that that's enough i don't
know if that's enough so i i'm excited
my excitement comes from the possibility
and the hope that they really said okay
we're just going to create a living
breathing world
and it's going to be
it's going to be a massive world you're
not going to find you're not going to
find
50 of the things in this world you'll
never find because it you know it's
going to take you 3000 hours to play it
or whatever i want them to do that
not that i'm going to engage with it to
that extent but
for me it's like
that's the next step if i'm looking at
at bgs studios and and where i expect
those games to go it's there
um so i hope i so i'm excited for the
prospect of it being that obviously like
again
they're human beings it can't be you
know we've already seen the expansion a
little bit of of what we can see from
open world games especially next gen we
look at eldon ring we look at other
games that are kind of expanding it um
something i've always always said about
that i want to see with more recent open
world games is i don't mind the game
worlds being smaller
if they're denser yeah and they're and
they're denser and they feel alive in a
way that no other game has before if you
tell me hey
this area is you know whatever 50
smaller than this other game
but you can go into every door and
everywhere you go into there's a story
beat there is characters to find to to
to learn about and find out and if you
give me that that to me feels more
next-gen than oh you know the surface
area of the world it takes you 20 hours
to get to one from one yeah i don't want
to see all that so
uh i'm
i'm excited i'm excited
you're not allowed the internet said you
cannot be excited for this they said you
have not seen gameplay
that's what they say
no no you're they're absolutely right
about that i mean again
but it's it's one thing to be excited to
see what somebody does and to be out
there being like it's going to be this
it's going to be that
i'll tell you i i was the first one
i was one of the first ones i called
fraud on my own let's go what are we
doing after after witcher 3
i was like cdpr i can't do no wrong
can do no wrong cause the witch
happened to you and that's what happened
to me fraud alert i can't even front
they you know they got a little bit too
big for their bridges you know and again
the the people in the suits made
decisions that were not beneficial to
the dev team in the game
and this is what happened um still a
great game
but when you think about what the
witcher 3 is and what cyberpunk is i
don't know it's not there so
you know it's always good to be cautious
to be tentative but excitement is good
why would i be like i'm i'm gonna hate
on this until i see it like what what do
i get out of that i don't get anything
out of that so for me like this i feel
like you could be cautious but to attack
people bg
oh he's got a little bb
i remember bg talking about cyberpunk we
like they've made one good game
they've made one good game
he said they made one good game and i
was like you know
when you think about i mean two was
great but two was still very much a pc
game
maria is the one that hit everywhere
right
and
you ain't wrong like all right do it
again do it again and then maybe i'll
have more faith in you and a lot of
people like nah that was there and i was
wrong so it's one of those things that's
like listen i i i'm excited i'm excited
for any new game that comes out that
that speaks to me at the same time if
when it drops it's not what it is it's
supposed to be what i expected to be
i'mma say so
you know whatever i i just i don't see
the purpose in being like i'm messing
with that until they show me i for me
yeah that's just too much anger to carry
with me right you can't carry that away
with your heart yeah yeah i'm not gonna
carry that with me until the until the
moment it's warranted you know what i'm
saying
to the computer all that anger in this
in the building the bike check might
check your beauty sir i want to make
sure we can hear you make sure you guys
see what's going on oh no yo salute
salute to your name change i see what
you got pro gameplay advocate
break down your position sir
listen i'm i'd just be trying to save
people from themselves that's how that's
how i see it
right because
i just you know to me it's like
how many times do gamers have to burn
their hand on the stove to figure it out
they go from like hyping one game
saying this is going to be the greatest
thing since pants with pockets
it lets them down then they get hyped
for the next game saying this is going
to be the great the next greatest thing
and it's like
you just got off of being beat in the
head by that last game why are you and
you listen you can be excited for a game
you know if even if you haven't seen
game play if you know the concept you
know generally what it is
but i mean bro there's people jumping
out the window saying this game is gonna
be the best game of this year one of the
best games ever you know it's it's gonna
be there's people think that thinking
that star field in itself just the name
is bigger than harry potter
not just the name
yeah that's wild i don't know about that
man but bg
isn't it just these dudes that want to
win
that that want that one win
that is starving so bad for something
other than gears forza and halo
and they just want that one win and they
think it says and they want to be the
first one to say i told you what it was
man it could be you know it's possible
and you know like i just feel like you
know it happened with cyberpunk you know
and and uh fallout 76 and you know a
bunch of other games and my thing is
like listen i'd rather i say a game
sucking it and and it ends up good
because then i'm surprised i can never
be disappointed if i think something is
going to be way worse than it is like
guardians of the galaxy oh that's a
cynical side of thinking of things but
you got to be hopeful
i'm i hope it does well
i just assume it's going to be bad more
than not right but like guardians of the
galaxy when i seen when i first seen
that game play like i was like yo this
looks this looks like it's going to be
terrible i played the game yeah that was
one of the best games yeah and see then
i had a different view on it because
when i saw the game play i was like oh
it looked dope
but i said that about the avengers
now i'm with vgo when i saw um guardians
i was like oh there's gonna be some
avengers during the game i'm good yeah
because that avengers left they left the
back yeah yeah
i i understand it is but good thing i
guess my question to bg is that i see i
see you go hard
on the gameplay aspect
we've been doing a cyberpunk situation
and i i gotta see it until i crown it
whatever it's gonna be crown is it is
that more your position yeah i don't
really like
like i believe certain studios are
better than better than others okay but
until you show me gameplay i don't
really care
like i i don't care like yeah i'll look
forward to the next
naughty dog or santa monica game but i'm
never going to be like oh man this is
going to be the greatest game ever like
i haven't seen it so to me like it's
it's literally nothing to me until you
show me gameplay i don't care i don't
care who you are
so show me pj let me push back let me
push back let me put that so the
pedigree of the studio don't be nothing
though like like like we know dory door
got a pedigree we know like certain
studios when they come outside rock
stars certain ones you don't see it when
they come out
you know
the history track records say yo
it's bound to be most likely good like
that still won't sway you i don't care i
don't care bro look because look people
i went to war with kojima's fans right
like
proclaimed this game was going to be
you know almighty right like
y'all haven't seen it though like and
then and then we'll be consistently
consistent i gotta get one when we got
trailers i'm like
we still don't know what it is i
remember they literally told me but they
really told me but they told you that's
what excites them about it i don't know
what it is i'm like
i can't what other product is there that
like you buy and we'd be like you know
what excites me about it i don't know
what it is
it's like mystery it could be chicken it
could be beef
what about the mystery mix now ladies bg
come on
there might not be any pre-orders dude
you buying furniture like oh i don't
know what it is
i see i can't i can't that's that's a
cynical thought
okay
because it did then there's no
pre-orders
don't mess up their bags dudes can't get
hyped like
i'm not
i think bg the way because the way it
sounds like to be bg like you're you're
saying like look you could be hyped for
the game but don't overdo it don't don't
don't over hide the window okay i like
those dudes that jump out there though
because i'm gonna jump out that type of
dude
right but
play king if you don't know nothing
about it right
you know what's crazy
i'm actually on bg's side with this game
yeah cause you you are yes what's so
crazy because you are the game play dude
you don't like cgi you don't like
trailers you don't like betas you know
what it is yeah i've been bamboozled by
these dudes for so long if you don't
like none of that why did you come at me
so hard over wanting to see starfield
gameplay
oh no no i didn't come at you yeah you
did that no no no i told you he said
yeah
set things up right now
you're talking about from a standpoint
of
when bethesda showed it
i don't care about that i don't care
what bethesda did before they got
married
that's your business yo history is your
history you start new today
right so today you're going to show what
we want you to show
and this is what i said
that was a no that was a new day so to
be honest with you all that star filled
screen that you got before that logo
that you got before that didn't exist it
didn't happen so when y'all saw her
walking on the ship and you saw all that
other stuff and they picked up the gun
that was the that's the first time you
saw starfield that's it
all right so the next time you see
starfield it better be play mm-hmm
and then a follow-up release facts i
agree i agree right so this is why
that's why i was like no that that 2019
crap that that whatever how many years
ago they showed it that don't count what
she did in the past don't matter i feel
that because microsoft has a different
agenda from what their agenda was like
you said they was probably showing it
when they was having a down cycle when
they put out fallout 76 and it was like
yo hold on man i know fallout 76 is
trash but we got this other starfield
thing that we're working on just to shut
people up and we've seen it was
literally the definition of smoking
mirrors right so
let me jump in i'm not going to fight
for this game at all right okay
but
at the same time i can get why xbox
dudes
is flying out the window
right because they want flying out they
want that god of war
they want that horizon i mean not this
one oh um don't do that and then you
can't say grand tourism
[Laughter]
they want something that sony do nice
just recently they've been in the toilet
bowl but i mean they want something to
hold on to they could say my
metacritically high too yeah cause they
dudes these i mean that's a fact they've
been taking these lumps so i i gotta
give those dudes that those window
jumpers dudes that you know bg say they
jumping out the window those dudes i
feel you i know you want it bad but if
you flop
understand bg come on oh no the fact
that this flops
oh my god okay
you had to receive some debt you'll be
ready and that's the thing like y'all
set up a game for failure more than
anybody else because
because it's the same thing i said with
cyberpunk right people
you know like like if if you go based on
metacritic scores which i'm not saying
that's that's right no
right but if you tell me
that this is going to be the greatest
game ever made right that's that's
literally what people told me about
cyberpunk and you know we know now that
that metacritic score wasn't exactly
exactly accurate because it was mainly
based on pcc yeah yeah right and it came
out too and i don't know what was it 87
or 86 it ended up being that that's not
reflective of the best game ever made
correct and so in 87 or 88 that's a
great score that's a great score like
anybody should try strive for that
but when you set the standard you tell
me this is going to be one of the
greatest games oh no yeah they do it
today e7 don't cut it yes that doesn't
line up with what you told me so i'm
holding i'm holding you to your
standpoint right you're on the feet to
the fight it's not mine it's not mine
i'm holding i know what you do see you
got to stop letting them dudes get on
your timeline
i told you about the 10 tweet rule man
these dudes you got to look at the last
10 tweets and you know if it's just all
pro one size she does not care but he
loves it
brooklyn i'll be from brooklyn he about
it me i'm like i'm not wasting my time
going to this could have definitely got
the receipt i got a whole album
after they drop it out and if it hit a
92 i'ma keep the hell out of it
listen i feel y'all to me with i agree
with bg is the fact that yeah dude sub
dudes you know they jumping out the
window it's going to be the greatest of
all time like we haven't clearly seen
enough
gameplay yet and it's they still got to
execute my thing where i'm different
from vgo that's what is i do believe
pedigree deserve a little respect with
this being the a team you know i'm
saying i can understand concern i can
understand yo we want to see more but
they did set expectations yo we're going
to show game play in summer so
and the pressure's on them to execute
right all i'm saying for me
you know i look at it like this is the a
team of bethesda right this is that now
to addict's point where i'm with him
where i think the mess up happened i
think this is why people like bg are
justified is because they talked about
it so
the announcement was like what is it
three or four years or whatever it was
right
in my opinion and i have no evidence i'm
just speculating
i feel that announcement was more pushed
by microsoft to say yo yo you're working
on something shown up that joint you've
been working on because let's be real
microsoft's last e3 the real initiative
about star 4 was to let people know it
was exclusive that was the first bullet
point remember when sarah ball came out
you know a lot of it was like yo by the
way
you could only get this hit like they
wanted to say that you don't say it so
to me that may have put because if you
look at bethesda historically they never
show gameplay they'll talk about
something and then when it when it come
out it'll be like the gameplay reveal be
like a month before the game about to
drop like they really hold things close
to chess it's really not like them to
talk and i was actually surprised they
even gave a release date remember they
was like yo 11 11 or whatever you know i
was like wow they really
want like i feel microsoft really wanted
that out but if you had it up top how
would god hire with them boys they don't
like to talk so i will say this they
need to execute the part that i'm
excited for is the part that i think one
of the writers said they're going for
this thing that's called
nasa punk so pretty much like instead of
like the the mass effect joint where
it's like sci-fi not based on reality
their joint is like grounded in reality
like and predictable like it's just
certain aspects of it that is exciting
like a realistic take on space for me as
a space dude yes i'm hyped for that yes
i'm excited for that yes they gotta show
gameplay yes this uh uh sunday i mean
the summer reveal is gonna be big and
people are gonna um you know hold on to
it but i guess what it is for for guys
like us that like the hard rpg mechanics
to hear them talk about going back to
the essence like attic said if you're a
fallout 3 guy you didn't necessarily
like fallout 4 as much because you felt
a lot of it was casualized streamlined
from the hardcore mechanics and i think
the hardcore rpg community is like yes
y'all saying or the right thing but to
bg's point they have to show they have
to execute i think it happened in the
summer but it's a fun one i'm glad we
have vg up here because he he clarified
like he had to get them that's all i had
to say i feel you bro boys later you
already know weapon with pockets
where they at what time bro brought the
podcast man we tonight 5 45 est yeah
come check us out if you want that
podcast what podcast is that i heard you
got like one of the biggest poc what's
the name of it
we do all right weapon will podcast
broken gaze hd the legend salute brother
always good job to the iron lords man
you already know bro thank you brother
that's love man because you always show
us love for the jump so we got that um
that was my last minute anybody got any
more balls before we move on oh we got
super chats which i window we good
got super chats all right let's get the
super chat get some chat
uh let me see
donald taco again
very combative yeah he's very spicy
today ten dollars also to say that
perfect doc has competition from other
fpf games and xbox game studios is
assuming it's going to be anything like
halo cod or doom that's like saying
fable is competing with hellblade 2 and
psychonauts see
you're kind of threading a needle here
bro like yeah
so you got to tell me that at a glance
a shooty shooty first person game just
doesn't look as
halo car doom yes
so my thing is if it comes out and it
does it has it's going to have elements
that these other games does right it's
just going to it's it's a first-person
game they're going to be elements that
are similar
if they're not as good
yeah
he's throwing jabs he throws the blues
if they're not as good then why make a
fourth one right so this is my thing and
you cannot look at joanna dark and be
like hey
her skill set does not translate well to
a third-person splinter cell-like game i
don't want that john you know especially
crystal dynamics the king's the third
person making that you understand like
it doesn't make a lot of sense i i
didn't really mess with perfect art like
that isn't that like a stealth game in
first person yep
part of it is yeah she has gadgets so
you can be stealthy you can i think it's
being straight up actually
i don't want to see it but anyway so
yeah like saying fable is a rpg
hellblade is a third-person action game
and psychonauts is a platform but like
it's not the same thing
it's good i love you
what's that
[Laughter]
what else we got the wise old game of
five thousand chat not saying star field
this deep but i heard it can take three
crystals yo crap
[Laughter]
[Music]
for 28 months thank you sir fronting on
bethesda for fallout 76 is like people
fronting on naughty dog for making way
of the warrior on 3d whoa oh gee talk
you guys are real where the warrior was
like how many years ago like it's like
you act like fallout 76 was the first
thing they made and then they made
fallout 3. like come on
wow
the realm is outside they're spicy today
they're spicy
oh my god
platinum five dollars
have a blessed day on a beautiful sunday
what's up brother
and we've got rnb r b aka the
underground gamer five dollar super chat
clowns jumping out the window for a
wolverine game and ain't seeing one
second of gameplay but i can't have no
excitement for starfield stop the
captain wow
i ain't nothing
game either i don't know
how dare you get excited how is she
gonna swing for a while
y'all good at jumping around the top of
the streets and cities i've seen that
gonna do it
you're not known for that
gonna make a wolverine car you're gonna
drive around in a car hop out
disrespectful
then we got donald taco five dollars
there are certain studios like naughty
dog bgs and from where you know what the
game will look like before you see it
only the finer details need to be filled
is that a good thing necessarily
is it like i don't know we gotta safe we
gotta i cannot wait to this game come
out only thing that i'm hyped for that
it's the current gen game yes and no
i do like that i do like that a lot
then we got har get cheney 10 super chat
let's face it ponies will say starfield
is a flop no matter what it can have a
95 meter flop it could have 30 million
players flopped it won't matter xbox did
it there for a flop
he's not wrong
he's not lying yeah i'm stupid
oh my god but i got you out next oh boy
then we got players i shut out the flame
two dollars
gran turismo more like craig theresa am
i right yeah yeah
queen telling no one jd gave her the two
dollars right after he said what fights
there we got necromancers remember for
five months hold up i got jumped for a
second uh
quest what is everyone's thoughts on the
halo tv show now with everything that
has come out before it before it airs
keep up the great work guys
um speaking of that
what we're probably gonna start doing i
haven't got like the logistics of it
we're probably gonna start doing a lot
more of like
our stuff on different forms of
entertainment on like members and
patreon stuff so because people want
more
of us that's not gaming yeah but the
problem is this is a gaming platform so
we have to find a different way of
presenting that information yeah we're
going to give it to you in the
background but at the same time you can
go to largergaming.net
and you can check out the lord's minute
where we talk about various different
topics and we go into the various
different things and you can see other
sides of the lords yes sir
and they're only a minute long so you
know yeah yeah
not that guy in that box down there
and if anyone from microsoft uh you know
watching like well you know you should
hit us up with a a screening of that
halo tv show you never know things could
happen that that'd be nice that could
happen you never know pull up
question for the lords what third person
single player narrative driven game are
you most interested in from xbox studios
or what studios can do it
um personally i want to see what a
compulsion has cooking that's for sure
he said he said um single player first
person or third person third person oh
crystal d
what was the question let's get it back
it's hoping what was the question
what third person single player
narrative driven game are you most
interested in from xbox studios or what
studios can do you know or oh right now
i mean it's going to be highlighted it's
gotta be helpful
i'm not even really looking forward to
hellblade
but i'm curious on what the flavor was
because hellblade has been made with all
of microsoft like there's no like they
might have started the beginning of it
like the planning parts of it but
microsoft has funded pretty much this
entire game yeah that's why i want to
see me set giants on fire
going to be the yeah
game that truly shows if microsoft is is
elevating these studios that's a good
point you learn a lot i think
psychonauts did that already
well i mean they they helped with
certain things but they weren't there
from the start to the ground up yeah
yeah that's true
what else we got then we have shroom
kingdom five dollar super chat in a time
with no splinter cell and metal gear a
third person perfect d
would be a breath of fresh air
i concur i like it very much i like that
all right
jeez dot attack a 10 super chat the last
of us two was game of the year elden
ring is looking like game of the year
and starfront has potential to be game
of the year if it's 60 skyrim with new
elements so yeah i think it's a good
thing okay all right all right all right
he wasn't coming at you
he cooled down
down
i think he he he let the brakes off man
i don't think he let the brakes off for
nothing he giving you a false sense of
security ain't gonna bust you upside
down yeah
listen my thing is this i get more
skyrim's fantastic if you just give me
more skyrim and don't elevate the game
oh i said you said i'm saying i'm not
saying it's an l i'm gonna play it
you're gonna play it but you want me to
think though just
just put it in a space type of
environment is elevating the game that's
not just skyrim
yeah because i mean they got pirates
that
clearly
will just pop i would find it yeah you
know i would find it disappointing if
true because it's going to be vaster
right but i would find it disappointing
if i get to the nitty gritty and
gameplay wise it just feels like skyrim
like so it's just for me it's just like
it's
but skyrim is an amazing game though it
is really really fun
i'm saying the skyrim is great i mean
there's parts of skyrim that could be is
the combat in skyrim
this is when red dead solve comes out no
this is i get a lot of flack for witcher
3 combat and knowing all right skyrim
combat is horrendous oh all right right
or wrong all right
like skyrim but i do want the stuff that
they didn't do the greatest to be
improved to be improved
yes i want to see that combat i do want
to see what star feels combat going to
be because historically you know the
joke and shout out to eric jackson shout
out to b buddy that joke was always he
said they'd be fighting like they got
butter now
flaming donut talker fighting with super
chats did they fight he's still going
but again
[Music]
that's just it man i'm excited to see
what they do and i will be slightly
disappointed if it feels uh
samey just grandiose we have a two
dollar street shot from flank can we
trust don he hates lord of the rings oh
oh
dawn flame don't be airing out my dirty
light we fight at you not a lord of the
wrecks god oh oh okay okay
so look we all caught up finally
mm-hmm
is ready he has been patient gran
turismo 7 i will set him up is back
online after a 30-hour outage so it
looks like so a faulty patch has caused
his shout out to tom warren of the verge
so yeah much of
um gran turismo 7 include it's including
its career mode and multiplayer was
unplayable for 30 hours developer
prolificity digital took more than 24
hours to provide an update on the
problems after the maintenance extension
proliferating digital has now apologized
for the problems the game is back online
with a new and functional 1.08 um update
so it looks like one of the game
designers talked about that there was
discovered an issue after the 1.07
update and yeah so besides that they
said that um the problematic update also
adjusted the reward systems for some
events meaning gran turismo seven
players get fewer credits if that makes
it even more difficult to save up
in-game currency for the top cars and
makes the game a lot more of a grind for
players so um yeah that seems like grand
prize seven um many users have flocked
to metacritic to leave negative reviews
of the game pushing its store user score
down to just a 3.2 so uh
[Music]
lily king wants to talk about this this
is his topic oh lord king gran turismo 7
what's what do you have to say sir
i feel so sorry for that dude that went
in there and spent 70 dollars and he got
home and the service was down
and 90 of that game is online which is
weird
that's crazy right no they they they
just presented
that game
no no no you got the arcade mode that
you can play that ten percent that are
you got outrun
you
put your game in and you got outrun did
it
did it
you didn't do that
yo so you said
my life's a grand transaction
wow
what happened to the cafe caffeine
online today
cafe clothes they can't be close
to you you know what's funny kids the
end game npcs go to work and they say
we're closed turn around and go oh damn
you got the xbox truck saying we
hired yeah we won't send you home in the
middle of the day so so my question is
this right mm-hmm
and
is sony feeling the pressure from
microsoft's game pass oh my god what is
this guys
please explain this to me
please explain this one it is yes it is
in
a matter of weeks apart
they release
two games
a titles right
they haven't gave you
the numbers for either
right and you know sony's about them
numbers that is true they usually brag
about when right
we sold the first week we soaked 1.7
million
you heard nothing you hear crickets you
hear
and you really don't hear nothing from
gran turismo because the service is off
but
yo y'all hear me okay my mom yeah you're
good yeah you good now
i i've i've noticed
that whoever's in quality control here
oh god
and being in rushed because
fact or not
horizon is shipped with some bugs
shout out to mr boomstick he said you
know he's a horizon dude but he had to
put it down and he said i'd get back to
him when they send the patches through
and get it fixed and he'll get right
back into it um
gran turismo
every time i hear more about it and this
is the game that i was probably really
the most excited for yeah we grew up
with gran turismo like right
licenses we used to do that
i'm like
the ray tracing thing put me off because
it
made me think in the beginning that they
was gonna have ray tracing throughout
the whole thing but then it's not and
they nobody talked about the downgrading
graphics
until you got the game and then they
talked about
how it was quadruple the price to
purchase cars that it was at a certain
price right and now you hear
that they dropped this patch
and this patch
made the grind harder yeah
shout out to the dude who found that out
and everybody complained
to force them to take it off because i
think they would have just left it in
there and let y'all just grind to death
and didn't care about it
but
this patch and they had to take it off a
game
that is really 90 of the content is
online
and then you leave them with an arcade
game this is a simulated racing game
yeah and the only thing that you could
play for 30 hours is rk
this reeks
of rush
it reeks of desperation to get these
titles out early
to put them out there in unfinished
states and in in in states where okay
we'll we'll patch it up we'll fix it
later yeah
and
i just think the quality
in sony like you said 3.2 3.5
and user
yeah not the dudes that are forced
to oh man if i say something bad about
sony angles
are you implied
are you implying
that certain reviewers of of so
little certain those you ain't they
ain't gonna slide up on you with the
desk no more
some dudes get skipped over
if they talk the truth
right i mean they got reviewers to
review a game
and then the day the game came out
a shot pop up
right so
again
i think they're i think
they're feeling
the pressure of game pass
to put out games to give their player
base
things to play and these games are
coming out in
broken incomplete states
and that is completely unforgivable
to put a drive-in simulated game
and you can only play arcade mode
for 30 hours
um
y'all think shout out to fuzzy belvader
he is a big racer
[Laughter]
you can't be doing that
he said the game is built around michael
transaction and he said it was still
they still have those um payout
reduction is still in place is what for
that funny play he plays flaws are hard
and all that other stuff but um start
with you addict you you know you you
don't care about racing too much but
what do you think about this situation
when it comes to it like
when it comes to the micro transactions
how i feel about that i think i said it
last time
uh as long as they don't
like artificially fluff the game out i
don't care if they put microtransactions
to this degree if you don't want to
spend three hours grinding to get a car
which
i don't play racing games so i don't
know if you spent three hours is that
artificially uh fluffing something i
know when i played forza with the uh the
horizon five review they were giving me
cars like it was no tomorrow like here's
the time where i'm like yo i found my
car stop
like stop giving me these cars like
it's just like look like
it it is what it is like i think it's it
shows a little bit more on terms of
what we should be accepting more than
anything like
if you reviewed that game
and they did some sly stuff like that
obviously i didn't review it because you
know i'll review forza because it's you
know it's it's a game that appeals to an
audience that don't mess with those type
of games but i wasn't touching gran
turismo for 20 football
so but it's just like i feel like if i
reviewed that and then they hit me with
the the okie doke switch stuff up at the
last minute
i feel like i would i would feel away
about that like i would
i might even low-key be like should i
review their games anymore because it's
just like
your name goes on everything when you
review stuff and if you come out there
with this information and someone picks
this up afterwards and they've changed
things up by putting microtransactions
in the game
at that point your name could go on the
line because when you have someone
watching that video or read that article
they're like yo why didn't you talk
about the these micro transactions in
the game like
i feel like there wasn't enough outburst
when it come to that i didn't hear no
one talking about that everyone was just
like oh like they would just make like a
like a tweet or something was like the
or updated on article and it would be
like uh you know they put these in it
and it's just like but that should
change the outcome of your review if
they're putting a system in to buy game
to buy cars now i don't know what the
currency exchange rate in that game is i
know there's a used car market thing in
there too so i don't know how long it
takes
fuzzy literally just answered it right
now not to interrupt you sorry but he
said it's 20 hours grind or a hundred
and eighty dollars u.s for a legendary
car that was 1 18 of the price in gran
turismo sport so so the price of the
brick went up
that shows
that they're artificially fluffing that
game to encourage you to switch i'll
give you guys a perfect example
i'm not the
biggest fan of the direction that the
assassin's creed games went into right
but odyssey
they put this this experience grind and
it's just so long but they're like but
yo we in this back door man we we we got
this brick that's going to just give you
double xp
and that's ten dollars
so they wanted an extra ten dollars and
now what that you know what that really
is that's what the xp was supposed to
give you from the start that they have
to encourage you to go out there and
spend money to get the full xp amount i
don't agree with that now luckily in
assassin's creed it wasn't horrible i
spent the ten dollars
[Laughter]
get that tag
when you look at something like this
i feel like if you keep letting them get
away with stuff like this like
and i get it a lot of this has to do
with money reviewers they need the money
that sony generates in terms of getting
the the review copies so they can
generate money by giving their opinion
and a view but it's like where does it
end
because then if they get away with this
thing and gta uh and gran trismo then
where does that end for the next thing
are they going to start putting
microtransactions yo it seems like these
reviewers are with it
we just got to wait for them to to get
the game out and get the review out
and then we drop the bad stuff it's like
we we as a community we got to be better
on that when when companies do some
anti-consumer stuff and this is sleazy
anti-consumer this isn't one of those
things where people do something because
they have to
they deliberately held probably the
worst feature of this game until post
launch just so the reviewers wouldn't
talk about
i it see a lot of people bringing that
up i didn't that's right at all i didn't
see it either remember
if i remember correctly these two there
was rumors that microtransactions going
to be in a girl in a forza game and
people obliterated that title
but when it comes to this that there was
actually micro transactions it is not a
whole lot of people talking about stay
in pocket
it's ridiculous
anyways so well what do you think about
this grand theft auto outage the whole
bit
i'm kind of with king um just on i was
excited to to play this game i haven't
played like a sim racer that's why i
messed up my guests
you know i haven't played a sim race in
a long time much less gran turismo it's
just been so long since i've invested in
this game back on the ps1 early ps2 we
were all in on grants oh yeah the
licenses and licenses and it was like i
mean the fact the amount of cars you had
like it was just it was a pretty amazing
product for the time
then we just sort of fell off and i i
kind of started caring more about just
arcadey stuff i didn't want to get so
invested into like
like i said the
license remember that
yeah that was crazy
so i was excited to see what a g a true
gt7 not gt sport that's mostly you know
focused on sort of esports stuff i
wanted to see what a true gt7 was and
what disappointed me was the same thing
like the disappointed king like
when you look at the next genus of it
the fact that there was absolutely no
ray tracing in game at all like that
that bothered me a little bit i was like
damn like what the hell what's going on
here like you know even if the
resolution goes down whatever i just
wanted to see it they've done it in
other games why not in grand theft auto
i saw someone in a in the discord
soft that they wanted a certain
car and they were grinding for it and
grand trizmo
they got this car saw and the surface
with that
oh
oh
no
oh no
what i was what i heard in the podcast
is this
individual bought forza motorsport seven
it got delivered to him
before the game went back up
wow that's crazy man and he said it took
him like 10 minutes to unlock that car
and it took him a couple hours to unlock
it in grand tr tradesmen
wow in minutes
and and four is a more supposed to say
yeah it is crazy so that that part of it
is nuts but then for me the other thing
was that
i've gotten to the point and maybe again
i'm not hardcore enough what when i play
these games i like to be i like to play
the outside of the car view i don't know
right yeah
i'm the same i'm saying i i like to see
the world i like to see what's going on
even in the you know in a more um
sim type game like a forza 7 or whatever
i'd like to see the world in that way
maybe i said that's not maybe that's not
hardcore enough because i know a lot of
hardcore players they play cockpit
inside the cabin the car cockpit you
know exactly
so i'm just like i
so in gt seven i was like okay let me
see the outside of the car view
and the outside of the car view is not
the inside of the car view it this is it
seems very plain
graphical it's just nothing it just no
it just does something about it like
when you compare like that every time i
see that game it's a very inconsistent
looking game like very inconsistent yeah
like again and for how i want the game
to look it just wasn't doing it for me i
was like damn i'm not gonna get it like
excuse me
so
that those aesthetic things aside right
i was never gonna engage with any of
this stuff to michael hey mind you
people this is a guy that plays the
switch
that's funny that's funny
if i wasn't hacking on a lung right now
[Laughter]
so
all this other micro transaction stuff
the fact that the game is so
online dependent mm-hmm it's just
it goes to show you this is a new sony
like
this is not hey we can pull up we can
put our game in this in the in the in
the you know the disk drive and you're
good to go like it's not that anymore it
is so dependent on this oh yeah we did
forget that uh well i mean we didn't
freak out forget that
you brought it up about the cars that
might be in 2017 that's
2017. yeah yeah so it's
i mean again
they're going to find their way through
this
and the product is again the product is
a quality product it just it isn't for
me and i think this sort of stuff they
need to figure it out because did you
hear the music in the game yeah no it
happened like yeah that's stuck it's
stuck back then it's stuck yo the game
itself is 2017. like it's that's crazy
2017 now if it came out of 2017 to be
next
[Laughter]
that's that's that's that's kind of
crazy to me it's like you know you had
all you took all of this time and i'm
sure the car physics and all that all
that stuff is exactly remember that
the car physically the flip yeah
and i get that but it's just like i
don't know man like it just it doesn't
feel
it's weird that people are saying it's
so forward-facing when it it doesn't
feel that way
and again i haven't played it just by
what why what i've seen and you
i don't know about the worst part about
it
all these issues we've talked about one
would think
all these issues that you talked about
one would think that we're talking about
a poorly received game right yeah but
this game
this game reviewed well not going to
sell well
they don't have cars past 2017. nah it's
been poorly received by the people who
actually purchased it and talked about
it
it's been well received by the reviewers
that got it hey man
i'm listening you know what it is
because i can't i can't say that because
i got friends that's reviewers right
yeah and i can't question their
integrity right because that's when you
you directly attacking these individuals
integrity that these games so
i'm not
directly attacking you in texas no no
you're going i'm not listening what i'm
saying is
if you know you're going to get a
certain type of response she's not going
to show up
to your house again next time
you know it's a big dance or something
like that
you might say favorable words to ensure
that it comes through and
that's human nature
because remember at the end of the day
they stake their lives on this stuff
that they do when they're doing these
reviews if you're a reviewer and this is
what you do you can't cut off the one of
the biggest fan bases
and say well you know i'll wait to the
game come out when usually the first
people out
get the higher numbers the most known
you're trying to get traction here so
you don't want to and you want to erode
any traction that you do have by pissing
off somebody because remember they are
this small the corporation is this big
i think that has to change in some form
or fashion
i think
like i i heard acg i like i heard
addicts say
review in progress
because when stuff like this happens
that way you can say oh these are my
impressions of said game
until i can give you a final review when
all the stuff is out
and that'll be good see i think the
problem with that is they didn't know
these updates are happening they they so
you can't really have that kind of
mindset because then you'll be like
every game is literally but then they
blindside it right
yeah i feel like that's that's a that's
an industry thing more than it is a
reviewer thing but i feel like that
the community and all the reviewers
should spoke more up about it because it
gets out of hand i mean i'll jump in you
know this one i'm kind of with solving a
sense like
you know gran turismo is a series yes i
grew up with
photorealistic graphics at the time we
were looking at those replays like it
was like oh my god like the next comment
like we've never seen anything like this
so i'm not going to be disrespecting to
polyphony but i got to keep it a buck
i'm kind of with king on this part like
i remember seeing the state of play and
i thought it was just me
i'm outside the car view kind of dude
and it i didn't feel the sensation of
speed for some reason yeah and i'll just
like don't
they'll tell you that this i think i
think acg said that specifically oh he
did yeah oh what maybe it don't it was
somebody who specifically said
it feels like i'm going at 20 miles an
hour
so here's the thing and i hate to do the
app because look we get it this is a
realistic this is a racing set right so
it's not going to play like forza
horizon because what's all right now the
race i completely get that but on the
arcade mode right
but on the counter
my thing is forza horizon 5 is doing
more like it's an open world game to me
from a technical standpoint that to me
is a bigger challenge as opposed to when
you're on a fixed track in my opinion
i'm not a developer you should be able
to put
way more detail
way more cloud and the satellite i'm
done with you right now information to
get the clouds together because they
want the sky
that you don't see
they want the sky
to be representative of what was really
happening at nuremberg that day
okay yeah no yeah no no but this is this
the type of stuff that
you know i who like they can say all of
this stuff but we don't know if he
really truly
because they talked about yeah this guy
is at a certain point and looks this way
and feels this way so it's going to
affect your traction on on at this
particular time of day and it's like
okay if you really went and
threw and did all the details for that
to be realistic in that way
cool
it's only gonna appeal to the hardest of
the hardcore right right it does do what
it's supposed to do right
yeah it's just for me it just takes all
that geometric sky engine get me right
trace
like i just it just didn't for me like
it just i didn't feel the sense of speed
i i don't like simulation anymore i'm
over that like even forza motorsport
like we're going to come out yeah i'll
check it out horizon yeah i'm her right
like horizon is all me they rewarding me
like alex said every time i play there's
credits going on i could buy a car i'm
about this you know what i'm saying but
as far as you know this joint i'm gonna
be honest i was not visually impressed
you know and then obviously it's a 70
joint you know it ain't in the service
that i'm you know i could try so i'm not
i'm not running out getting that and
then i got a shout out you know how to
get i gotta give um rich review tech he
kept it a book or something oh that was
great he got it he got a video out of
him in his editor and they really broke
it down and they you know they they
broke down the reason why these are fans
of the series and stuff like that so
then you throw the micro transactions
aspect which we hear in a pretty
egregious and then you throw this online
thing like i have no interest of what's
going on over there like i i
all these were there was red flags for
me coming in because i was like oh
simulation i'm out even if it was the
most amazing even if it had ranger i'm
out i don't want to do the hardcore
tweak the engine for the dudes that want
to do that god bless that's all you i
want to get out there i want to race i
want to have fun and that's where forza
is for me you know what i'm saying but
the thing i will say the
the horizon correct the thing i will say
for me and maybe i'm maybe i'll get
killed for it i just don't think it
looks better than forza horizon 5.
that's just me personally i don't know
and they don't move faster and to me
what playground is doing i feel that
they've been left that's just
the people with their hands in the back
and the thing yeah but they they put a
lot of that work in the sky hey i'm done
with you anyway it is what it is
[Laughter]
they're using the power of the clown
you're ridiculous i already knew it this
is what you wanted to do i already knew
what this was they really okay so
remember you crack down they really
using the power to crush okay
that's the best guy who cares about the
sky at a race again
especially when you're inside the car
right in the cockpit and you can't see
the sky and you can't see this guy
that's what it's lit
really working the most when you can't
see it
i
can't he just wanted to get his balls
off
it's the dopest thing this is the best
bamboozle they ever did they should have
took all that extra money that they used
for the sky and worked on that server
because y'all was playing arcade does
the sky work in the arcade mode i'm done
with you right now anyway
that's all i got on this situation
so if you want to get this to tell you
you want to get the poll and then you
get some chat uh we just got a few it
wasn't crazy okay second so i could get
a ball i could knock it out oh new iop
poll with the recent announcements and
gameplay reveal of hogwarts legacy
which of these games posed the biggest
challenge the elden ring for game of the
year 2022. the choices are eight harry
potter fans stand up we now have a new
challenger hogwarts legacy looks amazing
b
god howard and bethesda's rpg a team
easily makes starfield the true
contender to the throne
see
soft appreciate this
if big link comes outside
y'all know what that breath of the wild
two gonna do
or c or d
we already told you stop the fight
game of the year been over l didn't know
i actually felt like
like because p a lot of people feel like
god of war in them could do it and they
could go to war breath of the wild uh
but i can't remember a podcast what i
was on but once you do that change it up
real drastically one time i don't think
you're going to get that same reaction
you want the shotgun especially if
you're using reused assets so um if
you're coming out here with the same
assets from 86
[Music]
no no i agree with that completely
though those if those two games
specifically breath of the wild too
and they're going to have to bring more
than just they got to bring more than
just more of that
well breath of the wild too actually
gonna have um textures different assets
i know who ain't though
i know i know who turned around is a
little too close to the door
your man gonna come up with the same
face kratos you got the same face on the
same face boy
you're ridiculous
same lines too boy
[Music]
playstation to tell the fans you need to
pay more we need more profits than apple
gt7 paid to to pay 27 2070 to get the
whole game we're gonna nerf it more if
you don't pay pay up ponies console
passion jesus
argentina
then we got lord metro two dollars two
dollars attack grand transaction seven
is seventy dollars
and forty dollar cars enjoy forty dollar
cars
i saw a hundred dollar cars like yeah
crazy
then we got bruno ramos diaz with the 55
brazilian reals
that game looks worse than the last
forza motorsport on xbox one s x so yeah
that is true yeah to me because that was
in full
lit and moving
six then we got called weeb
two dollar super chat the shop was a day
one patch was it yep oh man
yeah yep we got raiden blade member for
13 months thank you sir hi lord so gt7
what happened to all your money in
progress or heaven forbid close the
servers down what happens to your game
all the money spent
it's gone to the bushes though
you spend all that money some service go
down to the bushes though
you outside
upset with the face yeah that's the
realities of gaming
that's the reality of digital games
that's the realities of games that are
primary online like when they decide to
turn it off
well we didn't think it was gonna go
down so early pause
happened so quick into his lifespan
ridiculous one week out his knees got
weak
there we got heart geek shitty five
dollars but sony has made their bed
review scores are inflated due to their
tactics have to call it out take away a
full point for their metas gt7 is the
77. yo [ __ ]
gran turismo skip leg day yo
yo you out of control you're out of the
pocket bro
you're out of the frog
to be honest gran turismo hasn't been
the same since three
the mechanics the physics is nowhere
near as good as forza gran turismo needs
new physics okay
they got it in the sky
you ain't gonna be out here
disrespecting the cloud game
ridiculous
then we got
otaku five dollars we chat forza horizon
5 was cross gen and one of the best
looking games of this gender that's true
that is true forza mortis boat eight is
next gen only and using the next gen
four's attack it won't even be closed
that's gonna be the thing it forces drop
if it falls or drops this year are you
freezing
yeah whoa
they do what it do that come out and
come out in september to the face buster
that'll be interesting
no no michael transactions
turn 10 be about day simulation i get up
there
and instead of worrying about the cloud
they worry about the tires on the car
there's stuff in the car you're
ridiculous not the stuff in the sky you
man
yo
king been waiting for this topic like
sony fanboys been waiting for eight
bumps last year for a new exclusive wow
y'all better seven five minutes continue
get him guys
bruno ramos diaz again with the 11
brazilian reals it doesn't look better
than forza motorsport seven it did that
yeah that's where i'm at with it
you know pick which you guys want us to
play
uh
that the choices are humongous
halo overcooked
and wwe 2k
yeah you don't sound thrilled about that
you don't want to play that w
w
yeah that's classic right there that
wrestling
doing it on twitter isn't really going
to get the initial thing we should
probably do it live on the podcast so
okay
okay
unfortunately it's like overcome we it's
it's either gonna be halo or 2k what you
doing after this you're gonna jump on um
elder rings i gotta eat first man yeah
we don't know he's gonna order some food
i'm gonna order some food because wifey
cooked last night at 10 o'clock yeah we
should always hope
yeah i told her i was like i'm coming in
right now she was like mm-hmm that
salmon was my and then she put the the
the
lemon she was like make sure you put the
drizzle with the lemon i'm like okay
cool then a salad bowl and she had to
she had the homemade salad that was lit
continue okay so
no taco five dollars for attack flight
sim the lords look amazing the sky is
flights him the sky looks amazing but
not the ground because you spend most of
your time in the sky at gt7 who cares
about the road that's sky though
[Music]
[Music]
but the wind is wishing that it is i
said it ten times but i'ma say it again
breath of the wild two were surprised at
how much it evolves compared to the
first another game of the year more
haters on the way i mean i tell you
something give me my temples that's all
i care about give me don't break no
breaking weapons and you guys
if if i see a megazord anywhere
in breath of the wild i'm i'm gonna lose
my i'm gonna lose i mean
if it's a departure like like like a
majora's mask was to ocarina of time
like yeah it could be
see and i like majora's mask i liked
ocarina of time i beat both of those
games but i just like both of those
games the center of the game was the
temples and i felt like breath of the
wild
they had like little
little machines that you that you go
across there's one on each side of the
map and and then there's then you fight
ganon that's literally the game and i
just to me that just didn't feel like a
zelda game like zelda's always centered
around temples
yeah this one hopefully that's it that's
that and yo we all call it the switch
yeah we'll caught up with super chat um
shout out to lydia lydian master
you know you down with wrestle question
i think we all down with wrestle quest
that looks nice i was happy to see that
you know the hold on they're coming for
um added claim up after a while one had
a megazord with the divine beasts
so they come in oh my
why do you think i said if i see a
megazord in breath of the wild too i was
referring to the divine beast
god see you guys not painted
listen addict is hungry hungry he needs
stickers yeah he got his [ __ ] we got
to get about it
you know how you get really hungry
anyway yo fantastic show salute to bg
pulling up for that little star field
no brooklyn in the building weapon
podcast lord addict where can i find
people find you what you got going on
sir you can follow me on twitter at lord
addict iop um i will be having uh the
triangle strategy review coming out
tomorrow at 1 30 p.m so it's premiering
uh so you guys get a little of a like a
little podcast scenario it's like 26
minutes long it was a pretty lengthy
idea
um i do want to you know some a lot of
you in the chat said you didn't know who
bg was
uh look
there
can you definitely go over there and
check out what will it's not our show
keep that in mind
uh
it's
they like to smoke oh yeah everybody
smoke and when i see them don't show
they like to smoke smoke they cuz they
do all that stuff so feel free to go
over there and check them out if you
guys want to it's but it's a good show
because it's a fun show
like don't don't feel like you're gonna
go over there you're gonna get the same
type of you know calm scenario
over here but they they have a different
way of doing business their business has
been highly successful for the stuff
that they have been doing and i do
appreciate that there's diversity in
what we can
say everybody definitely have a more
mature uh show
and and and different take on things
yeah love day stuff oh yeah funny real
quick
oh
when i go i'll say it okay i'll say it
all right google
so how we're how we're going to do this
is i'm going to after the show we're
going to talk for a couple minutes about
how we're going to do this community
thing get a good day and then what we're
going to do is set up the day we're
going to stream it uh i guess it's going
to be 2k
probably going to be a couple weeks
though guys because uh solve lives at
work so it's going to be a couple weeks
before we can get a good time for him to
be able to participate
i have not played a wwe game or any
wrestling game since like since like the
n64 so that means he's gonna be nice
when he get in
i'm just pointing that out there um
definitely catch uh me and king are
gonna stream um
elden rings sometime today after i eat
and you know pull up to that triangle
review man i know yeah for sure like
week late uh i can't help it nintendo's
hard to like reach out to to get like
review copies and stuff uh but you know
definitely go straight that means he
paid for his own that means his review
is gonna be real
and
with all the detail i'm like damn if you
put them side by side hold on
let him talk if you like them
they're different uh so definitely he
said if they step by side they're
different i'll put them side by side
what's up
a nintendo switch but you got to lose
man see
about it ain't a lot over there to play
right now so you might as well look at
this they're eating you to the doctor's
office to go get your cataracts
you know they give it up you'll see what
it is so 1 30 tomorrow right that's what
is going up 1 30 on this channel
premiere
world world premiere world world
probably i'm gonna get that i'm gonna
get that that voice and put it at the
beginning of all
okay right now here's the dilemma with
the attic show because i know a lot of
people are asking about it okay i'm not
doing merchandise right now please stop
asking
uh second off i i do i i i inside the
hour stuff
you have an attic shirt
why addict show merch
i want to clarify
i do have a guest that can only do
tuesday so i might do one or two more
tuesdays and then we'll move the attic
show to wednesday okay okay no doubt
absolutely same time 5 p.m 5 p.m you
already know right here on ilp shout out
to hustle and motivate the co-host you
already know
lord solve what's going on what you got
ah not much now you can look out for me
and lady april on the latest lord's
minute we'll be talking uh details of
hogwarts legacy very exciting lord's
hour
the lord's hours in april
is different i'll be doing i'll be doing
that after i eat just like addict um
that's about it i see if i can get some
gaming in this week i actually i really
wanted to try tunic uh you know you know
zelda old school zelda likes are my ish
you know i still haven't played that yet
yeah you're gonna love it mm-hmm
and that's it god cool oh shout out to
zorka 87 in a giant legacy look raw you
already know solo rdx in the building
lord king where can i find people find
you what you got going on sir
hey zalka go to the beginning of the um
stream
that's when i talk about batman oh yeah
yeah yeah
i had to talk him off the edge oh
detective talk let's go he he he's
definitely not about it
okay i see some there's
resistance details
me and him have a good conversation
i'll direct them in the direction
you direct them in the right direction
are you supposed to feel about the move
and then then i can give him back man
1990 if you like that stuff i can't get
it with you you know michael keaton he's
a good he's that that's a good vlogger
don't ask me about that damn movie bro
listen you went in there expecting
something else you got what you got
now you're gonna like what you got and
that's it
eat your best booty shut up
we got it now we got it
go to lords of gaming.net
where you can see
me and ty
yeah talk about the miss marvel trailer
yeah i gotta watch that so you put that
put that out
so a lot of you dudes don't know about
kamala khan yes it's a disney plus show
it's coming on right after moon night
it's gonna run parallel to the ob1
so
ty and i will be very busy because we do
a lot of disney plus stuff yeah y'all be
in your bag
and i really wanted to talk about the
sonic trailer but i think this week
we're going to talk about the sonic
trailer because i'ma tell you man that
thing blew my socks off on pause but um
go to hey hey
hey
there it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
go to twitter where you can find me king
david otw
uh
having the best time of my life yes
playing with these dudes post um go to
iron lords podcast
on
instagram
on twitter
and on facebook yeah
and i think we have a presence on twitch
right yeah we're gonna they've got the
twitch and we're working on the tick
tock
okay so also today i will be streaming
elder ring with attic helping me out
killing some of these hard crazy bosses
helping king get a little bit forward
you want to see how king do his thing
you're going to see how addict do his
thing once he gets some food in his
belly yeah um
and that's that's uh king david ilp okay
on twitter on twitch twitch
i got to start saving my stream so you
guys can actually laugh all day and the
reason why i got on the hoodie so y'all
can see it says
hill figure hell figure
in the street
shout out to the spaces that makes
figures about keg new jacket for every
space
30 days ago 30 days of course how are
you doing man he's outside so look at
this with everybody pull up everybody to
check coming through 500 yeah hit that
like button i'm saying tell your mama to
your mom's mama do what i'm saying get
that drink but
listen
so um yeah so it's brought to my
attention due to king and attic
stitching that i have to
play this um game king is going to break
down all the complexity of how to stream
for me so i probably won't do it um
i might do it on a saturday i might do
it on a saturday provided we ain't got
no movie or nothing
all the way next week the movie where's
the movie
hey when's the movie um i mean we gotta
we got more videos coming up was this
saturday no no no not this saturday
night is april first
i thought
so i was gonna say i wouldn't be able to
do it don't listen to me oh
so how streaming works i connect the
system and then
how does this do right here very simple
go to your link when you link your
account and stop playing i just don't i
don't know i want
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just don't understand how to stream
for the people i've never done
around here this is goofy so okay i
figured it out he said you know
obviously
weaving
i don't know i just don't know how to
stream he's these guys are expert
streamers so he's an i.t guy
he's the guy
like if i got a problem he's the guy
this is just dude it's a new territory
for me but i'll figure it out for the
realm for the realm
[Music]
he's the guy that picks up
so yes i gotta
show you stuff look out for i might try
to do it quicker than that and um you
probably get
an hour or two of this foolishness no
it's a two-hour stream oh that's what it
is
i gave them two and a half years and
today i'm going to give them a good so
y'all get two y'all get two joints
cog playing eldon foolishness and we'll
let me know i'll let y'all know how i
feel about it i'll give it i'll give it
a honest shot
i'll give it an honest shot see what it
is you know what i'm saying i love it me
and him did kings phil so i know who he
is
yeah we're gonna see i'm just trying to
live a peaceful life
samurai
yeah yeah yeah so what's that double
shot
okay okay okay all right let's see what
it is but anyway that's what i got again
support the movement um as far as
everything oh so look everybody i see
y'all out here getting y'all sour i see
y'all getting that advance gg i see it
y'all are doing your thing see y'all
with those road to packs and i see the
road to the packs
yes i'll put the revision out yes oh let
me hit y'all delay
yeah hit the link right now
it's the revision is five i changed the
um
the color of the logo yes so go in there
check it out and
link's in the description right now go
check that out yes cog is promoting this
powder so what anyway um
hey don't judge me i'm moving wait so um
we got the thing we go go check out
king's updated version it's really fun
check it out and if you come into pax
east boston lords will be there pull up
with the shirt we're going to take
pictures we will give some love that was
is what's up so that's all i got yeah
slimy rock rock 10 up that's the link go
breath of the wild is the closest game
to the og the legend of zelda every game
after that stuck to the link to the past
formula breath of the wild is the most
zelda-like gazelle of the game
that is true so i get the dungeon
because i like it
temples is that how we're going here oh
wow
exploration parts you're saying that
with food in the mouth
crumbs coming out of the bag coming
out of the beetle we doing that
here we go
taco five dollars in the chat we eating
over here nintendo land triangle
strategy new mk a new moto
mk8 mario kart 8 tracks
[Laughter]
[Music]
how what's the legacy at the end of that
legacy baby
let's go oh you ain't got elder rings so
you need something
yeah we got then we got doovey movies 60
bucks 500 plus in here hit that like
button bye thank you sir yes sir then we
got four's a legend five dollar super
chat sonic the hedgehog two movie might
go down as the best video game movie to
ever come out it won't even be close so
much reference
because they fixed sonic i don't care
what they do with sonic i will buy every
ticket they do and the movie because
they
because they took our theme yeah and
they took him back to the drawing board
it cost the millions yeah they did that
because we was on their ass
you know he loose yeah you know he loses
me loose he's funny though i would i
would have loved that cash fire
[Laughter]
i would have loved to see the trash fire
all the time
[Music]
see you next week
is that the end of the season with you
oh wait hold on is this one in
yo i like that one i like that one that
one's fire
is that the end of jessup yeah that's it
all right look everybody go get go get
that you know what i'm saying gotta hit
y'all with that focus right quick cold
iron lord on the checkout do that we out
see y'all next week
it's down to the mosey going down over
to the website go check it out whether
you're gonna get that focus for the
gaming session that energy a little perk
for the gym we want to get some swag
some merch maybe an ice shaker go run on
over there check out the products but
again really cool products they don't
hide behind any type of proprietary
blend
nonsense it's all transparent as far as
the ingredients the label green tea
caffeine kind of a healthy form of
natural caffeine none of that crash none
of that stuff so yeah again go check it
out you run in there you add it to your
cart use that referral link that we got
in the description and then you make
sure on the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by advanced
gg so check that thing out
[Music]
do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
don't